Neil deGrasse Tyson is with us he's a
leading astrophysicist
Neil deGrasse Tyson is with us he's a
leading Astro
you
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by 23 minutes away from a
Donald Trump press conference during
which he will announce unless something
changes a national emergency around
coronavirus cove at 19 and of course
this is likely to do two things it is
likely to cause more panic hoarding of
toilet paper and 50-pound containers of
rice and the like but hopefully it will
also get enough people taking this
seriously because a lot of what's going
on is just math and if we don't get
people self isolating and staying away
from others until such time that there's
time to test antivirals I have news
about that until you know it's gonna be
months at minimum maybe a vaccine can be
developed there's really nothing else
that can be done until that time and we
have to we have to stop the spread there
are some countries that have done it
successfully eventually with extreme
authoritarian measures we're going to be
looking at those numbers I have a whole
bunch of different stuff to look at
maybe some before and maybe some after
Donald Trump's speech expected at the
top of the hour and then of course
remember that there you know so many
people who insisted that this was
nothing and this is all you know if the
Brazilian president now has coronavirus
after almost laughing it off just days
ago it's there's probably a 35% chance I
would estimate that Donald Trump himself
has it you might remember he didn't look
well during his announcement his address
on Wednesday night that right eye was
swollen almost completely shut even more
labored breathing than usual who knows
there are worse case estimates that 150
million Americans are about 1 in 3 will
eventually have this and we are going to
simply have to wait and see and and do
what we can do information that there's
not only a viral spread of the virus
there's also a viral spread of
misinformation everything from black
people are naturally immune to drink a
bleach concoction to cure it all the way
to
there is testing I mean part of the
disinformation shockingly is coming from
the President himself and maybe we will
even pull up well we have a little time
here I'll pull up I tweeted this list
earlier I've been tweeting a lot of
different stuff today much of which
we're going to discuss where was it the
list sorry for the fast scroll here's a
list of Lies told so far and this is
very small I don't expect people to be
able to read it but it's a dated list of
the lies that our own administration has
been has been spreading and perpetuating
and it's really really bad to consider
retweeting this I think that it is
definitely of some value to understand
the degree to which even our own
administration is telling us things that
are that are untrue not drinking bleach
by the way drinking chai tea as far as
what we're doing at the David Pakman
show we are we are basically moving into
a work-from-home scenario over the
weekend and already we're gonna start
mobilizing technical resources we're
gonna dis basically disaggregate and
decentralize the production of the show
and I'm going to be filming from home we
are gonna be doing you know cutting
clips from home Pat may may briefly
spend some time in at the office our
building is not closed in any way but
far fewer people that are going in and
you know some people wrote to me and
said David this is your it seems like
you're overreacting well the whole point
is we don't want to be behind the curve
and if we're in an office with hundreds
of other people who rent space in the in
the building we may be sick and not know
it
listen I think it's possible I have the
virus can it's it's remotely possible
ten days ago I had just the the
slightest cough and no other symptoms
and I've read you can have basically
almost nothing for two weeks it's
conceivable that I've had it for ten
days and in three days I am going to
experience some new symptom we just
don't know people aren't being tested
and and so I am out of an abundance of
caution I'm also going to be sort of
sort of self quarantine to the degree
that that is possible
so so I don't know what else I I would I
do want to mention by the way one of the
big horrible things that has been going
on is that YouTube flatly demonetised
all coronavirus content dubbing it a
sensitive a sensitive issue an issue of
a sort of like a localized sensitive
issue that's not brand safe I have been
notified and this hasn't happened yet
but I've been notified that YouTube is
going to be whitelisting some channels
that they have determined our
authoritative sources not disseminators
of disinformation on coronavirus and
they will be white listed for
monetization on coronavirus content and
i've been told we are one of those
channels and this is a very small small
group of channels so we're taking this
very seriously we've been reporting on
this for months at this point in time I
know many of you know that and we're
going to continue doing that and it is
important that the the channels that you
believe are helping to not escalate
panic and also reporting things as they
are we support those channels it doesn't
have to be this one but there is a small
small group of us and I've been told
that the david pakman show YouTube
channel which as you know has over
800,000 subscribers and we're taking
this seriously there's a responsibility
associated here I'm told that we are
going to be whitelisted and it's a
really big move excuse me just having
having my chai tea so okay so we're
about 17 minutes we may watch this on
the PBS channel my guess is that the
Whitehouse channel may have a live
stream coming up soon as well although I
am not seeing it yet so we will see that
let me answer some super chat oh let me
just do things in order we have we have
plenty of time to talk about what's
going on okay on twitch let me say thank
you to Dems Eero cool for the
subscription OSHA Nova says hey David
are you having any shortness of breath
no no shortness of breath right now
Chris rads subscribed with prime perturb
0:08 subscribed with prime says Trump
would definitely be a high risk patient
he is obese old and not in good shape
and Comstock rocker has also gifted a
subscription I very much appreciate that
I also want to say thank you to manraja
banes who is has just subscribed at join
pakman.com taking advantage of the
coupon code you see right above my head
20 20 now that does save you 66% and I
really appreciate all the people that
have been supporting our channel in our
continued coverage you know we when we
were first when we first learned all
coronavirus content was demonetised two
and a half months ago and we started
covering this we said we don't care
we're going to keep covering this
because this is clearly becoming a
bigger and bigger thing and we've
continued to cover it we've just been
notified we are going to be white listed
as an authoritative source on the issue
by YouTube by next Monday that's a big
deal but we've been covering it the
entire time because it is so important
okay super chats coming in we're just
waiting for Trump at the top of the hour
Dan stepka says how can I immediately
buy some short sales the second he opens
his mouth the market is going to crash
even more yes so we we are watching that
here is the stock market as you can see
it's been an up-and-down day down to
almost let's actually get the intraday
just because that's better one day here
we go so the markets opened
significantly higher 6% higher they got
down all the way to being only up a
quarter of a point we're now back up to
being up 2.8 7% I hope this doesn't
happen but I worry as soon as Donald
Trump declares a national emergency in
20 minutes the stock market will will
again implode and it will be very bad
for a lot of people's a lot of people's
retirement accounts so we're all just
waiting to see Dutch Morgan says if
Bernie won the nomination and went
against Trump do you think Bernie would
say Trump is his friend and is electable
I have no idea I have no idea we are
seeing by the way I did also put out a
tweet a few minutes ago let me let me
get this on screen I'm managing a bunch
of different things I want to go over
with you guys I said I guess it's time
to ask do any of my followers think
Trump will use today's national
emergency declaration combined with
something else forthcoming to try to
delay the November election a national
emergency you know I am NOT
conspiratorial in this way but I'm
asking you the question
what do you think about it and you can
let me know on Twitter if you want or
send me a message otherwise and we can
explore that possibility I believe that
Louisiana primary has been delayed by
it's either 2 weeks or 2 months who
knows I mean again we're trying to keep
up with the the spread of information
ourselves let's see here Matt bond says
the Australian Minister of Home Affairs
positioned for cove at 19 and was with
trump barbie trump and bill barbie last
week the don got three
up-close-and-personal so far yeah
Trump's been exposed to a whole bunch of
people that either have or are suspected
of having having the virus inconsolable
says can't wait for another
miscommunication that results in the
further collapse of our national economy
yeah I mean look you know consider the
number of Lies that Donald Trump told
and we're just monitoring whether the
White House is going to have a stream as
well otherwise we'll pick it up directly
from will pick it up directly from PBS
which is safe as far as we know you know
Trump's Wednesday night address included
three major sources of disinformation
was one was saying European travel is
just shut down the truth is it doesn't
even apply to American citizens and
residents you can go back and forth you
may be quarantined it's unclear but
really we're talking about foreign
nationals number two Trump said it
applied to trade and cargo it didn't and
number three Trump said insurance
companies were waiving all co-pays for
coronavirus treatment that was untrue
they were waving at the time co-pays for
coronavirus testing in Massachusetts our
Republican governor is actually not
handling this poorly Charlie Baker he
has been involved in getting
Massachusetts insurers to actually waive
co-pays on treatment which really is a
big deal and again Trump was reading a
teleprompter meaning someone put the
lies or the disinformation on the
prompter which is absolutely insane let
me say thank you to Adam Adrian Adam
Adrian is new member number two today on
my website at join pakman.com I really
appreciative
but I'm doing it because I want to be
ahead of the curve instead of behind it
and I really appreciate everybody who's
been who's been supporting the streams
and our work let me say thank you to Wes
smoke for the super chapped inconsolable
says Seattle is in serious trouble
restaurants and businesses closing
people losing jobs not being able to pay
rent it will take years to recover I
believe that that is true I believe that
that is exactly right Auri opposed says
David thanks for your honest and
level-headed news thank you thanks to
Michael hag for the super chat Kevin
Shan hey David your coverage has been
indispensable on this only thing I'd say
is watch your wording on what exactly
the Fed Relief means great work thanks
the sh rome for grabbing a soy boy
membership Erin Washington says if you
think the corona virus is bad let us not
forget about all of the ancient diseases
and illnesses that are trapped within
the melting ice due to climate change I
don't know anything about that
scientifically so I'm not going to I
don't want to spread any information
that could be inaccurate I'm I can't
comment on that thanks to David Garrett
for grabbing a soy boy membership alien
piece as hello from Germany David keep
up the work d Cosby this is starting to
feel like Stephen King's The Stand look
out for Captain trips it is feeling
dystopian I'm not going to lie it is
feeling very very dystopian David
Garrett has upgraded his membership to a
beta membership thank you I appreciate
that
as well thank you also to gin sin on
twitch for grabbing a twitch Prime
subscription Oh are people saying that
the stocks are already starting to tank
just that just this tiny bit it doesn't
doesn't see it actually went up and then
down while we were tied listen if
there's gonna be a big move it's going
to come when Donald Trump speaks at the
top of the hour we're just about 10
minutes from that and we are standing by
for the White House feed and if we can't
get that vo here it is here's the White
House feed very good all right so we've
got the White House feed ready to go and
this is going to start momentarily okay
I have so much stuff to go through with
you guys I don't even really know where
to start just a couple of things and you
know Donald Trump doesn't really
understand this stuff at a deep level so
you're not gonna get any of this
for him here's the type of question that
is going to be a societal question I
don't put so I want to be really clear
about something I am NOT going to come
up with any theories of my own about the
coronavirus thing it's it's just too
serious and it's irresponsible so you're
not gonna hear me talking about what if
this is some kind of weaponized thing or
any of the stuff I will report to you
disinformation and what experts are
saying one of the things scientists are
talking about is what are we going to do
for example if pretend presented with a
possible vaccine which normally would go
through animal testing this is an
article on live science about
researchers who are essentially ready
and already recruiting as this article
says a clinical trial for an
experimental coronavirus vaccine has
begun recruiting participants in Seattle
but researchers did not first show that
the vaccine triggered an immune response
in animals as normally required i
tweeted about this and you can respond
to me on twitter is this getting so bad
that there is a case to be made for
skipping the human animal trials and
going right to human testing or not what
is the parameter that would be used to
determine whether it is or is not
appropriate I don't even pretend to have
the answer on any of this stuff what I'm
bringing to you is this is the type of
thing that's going on if you google if
you do a news search for coronavirus
vaccine you will see that there are
multiple vaccines that are essentially
ready for testing on humans except for
the fact that they've not been tested on
animals yet what do we do I don't
pretend to have the answer I'm merely
telling you that this is something that
that is being explored number two if you
google I've been keeping up with this
daily coronavirus antiviral okay there
is a drug from an Israeli pharmaceutical
company REM des aveer REM des aveer I'm
not exactly sure how it's how it's
pronounced this was developed
potentially for use against Ebola and it
didn't work against Ebola there is the
idea again some experts are optimistic
that it or something similar could work
on kovat 19 I would be following this
very very closely but again we
- remember that imagine that testing is
done and this is a good thing we are
going to have a supply problem because
we are soon going to have it you know we
don't have a hundred thousand active
cases yet right now the number of active
cases is 66 thousand but as you can see
the number of active cases after
declining from about mid February to
early March is now rising dramatically
we are going to need you know if a lab
can get a thousand of these we're gonna
need a hundred thousand of these so this
this is a drug I would encourage you to
Google this this is an article from
Scientific American as well the the
potential of antivirals REM des aver is
the one that has potential at this point
in time and that's all it is
all it is is is potential let me say
thanks over on twitch to a sipper path
our JC a and LeDoux Fionn for sending
bits and subscribing I also want to say
thank you to Cori fellows whose new
member number three on my website join
pakman.com Harry Alden is new member
number four at join pakman.com and also
oh is that everybody oh and Dan stepka
is new member number five at join
pakman.com really appreciate that
support support of any kind is much
appreciated okay
other super chats that are coming in
let's see here
okay parrots here and hey pair great to
see you the doctor I mentioned earlier
is called John Campbell sorry that I
didn't check first yeah if if somebody
wants so this I'm not I'm not gonna
recommend anything that's bells and
whistles okay every day sometimes twice
a day dr. John Campbell who I believe is
a British doctor is looking through all
of the news of the day related to corona
virus and giving people an update and
evaluating what's going on in in very
simple terms I highly recommend dr. John
Campbell's channel Jackson Hannon says I
used to say that it would take something
catastrophic like Trump's saying the N
word for Democrats to win Senate seats
in South Carolina Alaska and Kentucky I
think something catastrophic is
happening yeah
there are a lot of polls that are
looking very good for some Democratic
challengers in the Senate in this in
this coming November 20 2011 cycle Brian
Campbell says Bernie said kovat 19 will
show our health care system flaws that's
an understatement
thanks to Melissa Kay for the YouTube
subscription a BB c-- now Taekwondo says
could coronavirus be bacterial and not
viral i I think the the medical
community would know that at this point
I believe that they are right that
everything I've read is that it is viral
and that it is a virus that seems very
clear Kevin all tiller says aren't you
worried that kovat will shut down the
porn industry very worried extremely
worried Santa Claus says rats will often
have a different immune system response
to vaccinations than humans with could
which could prolong the clinical trial
testing but without the rats the risk
could increase no good answer here it's
a difficult situation Jay Harper what
policy proposals do you like from Joe
Biden well do I like them better than
Trump's I mean Biden's tax plans better
than Trump's Biden on his website says
he supports the green you deal yeah the
question is like like compared to what
is always the question in politics Erin
Washington says we shouldn't be
torturing other animals for our own
benefits to begin with quite frankly
that's a that's a controversial issue a
lot of people have different
perspectives on that yeah guys I do know
the question of whether corona virus is
actually a bacteria and not a virus
that's it's it's almost crazy to even
suggest that at this point in time let
me say thanks to Isaac Nixon who is new
member number six today really
appreciate your support Isaac I also
want to say thank you to Ted Wilson
whose new member number seven today if
you're just joining us we are just
minutes from Donald Trump's press
conference he is expected to announce a
declare a national emergency around
corona virus the guy who five days ago
was saying it's under control it'll go
away on its own everything's fine is now
declaring a national emergency on
coronavirus but it's the right thing to
do um it's the right thing to do if
you're just joining us on YouTube please
make sure that you like the stream some
we have 4200 people watching and only
300 people have liked the stream the
likes really do help us bring in more
viewers because YouTube is more likely
to recommend well liked streams and also
make sure to hit subscribe we have been
and will continue to we're actually
planning around large amounts of
coverage around coronavirus YouTube has
told us they are going to be
whitelisting us to monetize coronavirus
content which has been a big
disincentive for a lot of independent
media outlets not us to cover what's
going on so make sure you like and
subscribe and we will be we're gonna be
following everything that's going on
with this we are dis decentralizing the
production of the David Pakman show just
in an abundance of caution to keep
everybody separate I'll be producing the
show at home
Pat will be editing social media ad
sales it's all going to be happening in
a decentralized way because I I don't
want to even conceivably be contributing
to the problem and so starting Monday
that's the direction that we are going
to be we are going to be going in okay
let's see here Joseph van Scoy says
Trump needs to shut up and let dr.
Anthony foutch II do to do the talking
thus far he seems to be the only one in
the government that knows what he is
doing yeah the the CDC dr. Brad field
Redfield something like that
embarrassing implosion yesterday or the
day before before questioning and in
Congress Kevin all tiller says the
boobies must flow is this a thing people
are actually worried about some kind of
holed up in porn production because of
coronavirus I have not heard that before
thanks to David Garrett for grabbing an
alpha membership ah med Shousha
says i'd literally in the name oh it's
literally in the name virus yeah no i
think the idea is maybe they're wrong
that the corona virus is a virus but
they're not lada has a link to the world
emitters dot info yeah we're I have that
I have that pulled up already we'll look
at all of the data here and there's a
lot to discuss and world ah meters dot
info is a good platform for it
inconsolable says this is the most
dangerous damaging partisan hoax that
I've ever seen well said netra Smith has
grabbed the soy boy membership Shay
nurse says lack of testing will
spread this like crazy Arizona
Department of Health standards still say
testing only applies to known contact
Jay Harper says do you really believe
Biden can beat Trump I believe depending
on the economic circumstances in
November both Burnie and Biden could
beat Trump in every recent poll Biden is
doing better than Bernie against Trump
but we will we can look at that later if
people want for now we are simply
standing by for Donald Trump's press
conference at the top of the hour during
which he is expected to declare
coronavirus a national emergency and
hopefully that will really get people
aware of what's going on I think that's
part of the problem because for example
New York City the MTA the Metropolitan
Transit Transit Authority in New York
City
today announced that there has been an
18 percent decline in ridership and it's
like that's significant that's almost
one out of five people in a city you
know with 8 million people but I don't
know that mathematically 18 percent is
enough particularly when the people
riding still are in very close proximity
I don't know what that's enough to
really mathematically get us to an R
that is below 1
so hopefully this declaration by Donald
Trump if anything will get people really
taking it seriously
I don't know okay some guy says I think
we have plenty of porn out already
Amelia Terhune says check out the report
on chloroquine and zinc treatment I want
to be really careful guys there are
people saying colloidal silver will you
know cure coronavirus I don't want to be
involved in in any possible
misinformation so I don't I want to be
very careful I don't know anything about
that and I'm glad to research it and I
will later but I don't want to be a
purveyor of disinformation in any way in
any way whatsoever if you're just
joining us on Twitch I appreciate your
you joining us make sure to hit that
follow button
we're almost at 30,000 twitch followers
monkeyville has grabbed the Prime
subscription Nick's the latter says
thanks for all your hard work David
DJ gibster says Ohioan here in
that I may have the virus yet can't get
tested stay healthy yeah there's a
report out of Ohio from the public
health officials there that they believe
one percent of the population in Ohio
meaning a hundred and seventeen or so
thousand people have the virus right now
if that's the case then we are we we
have a real mathematical problem in
dealing with this okay Kevin L jeweller
says he's already watched all the porn
so he's worried about porn production
under kovat okay
Dillinger's see attic says Governor
Abbott declaring a public health
disaster
Sam Dean says happy Friday the
thirteenth mate you rock Dave thank you
appreciate appreciate you joining me let
me say thank you and welcome to Leslie
Goodman Malamute Leslie as new member
number eight at join pakman.com you can
grab a membership it's very quick easy
and if you if you appreciate the work
that we're doing there's a super simple
way to support it if we're talking about
a couple bucks
literally join pakman.com and that
coupon code 2020 now will save you 66%
phylogeny says even in South Korea with
their math screening and robust
treatment quarantine that lower kovat 19
mortality it's still many times higher
than the flu and climbing fast point 84
as of today I thought it was lower than
0.8 E for we can look at that data
momentarily I'm seeing South Korea 71 oh
that is point 84 you're right you're
absolutely right at there at about point
84 I believe that the action often times
0.1 is thrown around as the flu death
rate but I believe more accurate is
something like 0.148 so that's really
like 0.15 that doesn't mean point eight
four is good it just means it's not
eight and a half times higher it's only
like five times higher I know looking
looking for small wins here and Italy's
Italy's rate is of course very very high
a very close friend of my dad's lives in
the in a northern Italian city and he
came down with a cough and fever and
vomiting a few days ago vomiting is not
a common coronavirus symptom I believe
it's believed it's only 13 percent of
cases and he now has pneumonia presumed
to be coronavirus pneumonia
and has been admitted to the hospital
and we're worried about him he's
generally in good health but you know
he's close to 70 and it's not it's it's
not good it's not good
also yeah I know by the way guys we need
to I am aware that you don't calculate
the death rate by dividing deaths by
cumulative cases what you need to do is
first you need to take the death rate
and divide it by the resolved cases
which include people that are recovering
once someone has recovered do you know
that they're not going to die and then
you adjust that for the number of
presumed unofficial cases which is a
question mark you know the US official
count right now is 2000 the real number
in the US could be anywhere from five
thousand to hundreds of thousands if
Ohio's 1% number is is to be believed
and we just don't know we're working
with incomplete information all we can
do is say is there anything I can do to
avoid catching this from someone and is
there anything I can do to avoid giving
it to someone if I'm carrying it right
now the answer to both of those things
is try to work from home try to avoid
being around other people there's
nothing else that that we can do until
such time that some kind of antiviral
therapy and or vaccination is put
together we're just moments from Donald
Trump speaking and declaring a national
emergency if you are joining me on
YouTube welcome I would very much
appreciate it if you do me there's the
very small favor of hitting the like
button on our stream as well as hitting
the subscribe button we will continue to
cover all of these live coronavirus
events and we welcome your participation
in them as well and it really does a lot
for our channel when people like the
stream and and subscribe when when we do
a stream very much appreciated okay I
see people saying that if i refresh we
are now over 2000 cases in the US I
wouldn't be surprised yes there we are
2018 is the official number but listen
folks this number is outrageously low
like I yesterday i tweeted that a
someone i know in the area had a fever
and cough
and was told don't come in we can't test
you and it's okay for you to go to work
which seems insane I think that it's
conceivable I've had a slight cough for
ten days it's possible I have the virus
I am self quarantine we just don't know
there's no way I'm going to get a test
there's just it mean it's just it's lat
there's it's zero chance that someone
like like for example it would be useful
for people in my situation to know if we
are carrying it I don't know so I'm just
staying home what can I do okay
other messages coming in let me see here
don't want to miss anybody
joseph jeremy lo says keep up the good
work timmy Lunsford david what do you
believe the best source for accurate
info is on the pandemic big fan thanks
for all you do there's a couple
different doctors that are very good one
is dr. john campbell who is on on
youtube there's also on twitter i want
to give you the name of this other
doctor that i started following
yesterday dr. dena
grayson is very good as well okay so i
would if i were you i would check out
the daily updates from dr. john campbell
I believe it's John as well as the
Twitter videos she's been doing like
25ish minute videos dr. Dina Grayson and
that's her Twitter handle as well dr.
Dina de na Grayson just like Alan
Grayson she's very good
she is a physician scientist and expert
on Ebola and pandemics and we're trying
to get her on the program both both are
very very good okay
carpe Donnelly says I understand the
president is who should be reassuring
the people but he looked and sounded
awful Wednesday night different
messenger might be best yeah I think
that doc honestly I would put dr.
Anthony Fauci in charge of all
communications on this but it's not
going to happen okay Amelia Terhune says
it's treatment used in malaria and
autoimmune okay I'm in a research that
yes someone mentioned if anybody can get
me a scholarly article on chloroquine
and zinc
I'm much I'm very willing to look at it
I do want to be careful that
till I am comfortable about something I
would I I would not want to say too too
much about it
Jackson Hannon says people spurning
Biden are idiots who think that moving
politics significantly to the left is
some kind of loss for progressivism
despite the fact that the practical
differences between Bernie and Biden are
nullified by a Senate to the right of
both Jackson I'm glad you're saying it
because if I say it I get crushed so
you're you're thinking okay
Zachary Schneider has grabbed a youtube
subscription thank you very much let me
thank a couple of other people a Charles
Floyd is new member number nine at join
pakman.com Charles I really appreciate
your support you know it's been
inspiring the number of people that have
written to me over the last couple of
days saying David you you've been
covering coronavirus for months when you
had a lot of other people in your in
your area I don't want to say who
disregarding it as a hoax
you know I've signed up for a membership
so on and so forth because we want to
support the work that you're doing I
really do appreciate that and on that
note I really want to thank Charles
Floyd for grabbing a subscription at
join pakman.com Donald Trump running
late not surprising the conference the
address on Wednesday night also was late
but we are standing by we are also going
to pay close attention to the stock
market right now plus 4% Donald Trump
for the day Donald Trump has not yet
spoken and we want to see where it goes
every indication in my mind
ladies and gentlemen that there could be
significant volatility after Donald
Trump speaks I believe that this moment
here was where this big decline where we
went from Plus where were we here we
were at Plus no here we were at mine oh
I see what we were at minus 0.1 we went
all the way down to minus 3 when I
believe it was announced that Trump
would be declaring the state of
emergency we will see what happens at
the top of the hour but yes a lot of
people's portfolios very very very
messed up people asking ok so listen
sometimes people ask me David you have
an MBA in financial planning give me
financial advice
I don't do that everybody's situation is
different how close you are to when you
want to retire your financial situation
and the White House has also started the
stream so I believe it's about to start
unless it's gotten delay does anybody
know about that we don't know hmm it was
scheduled for 3:00 p.m. Eastern which
was 10 minutes ago okay we don't nobody
knows okay well we're just gonna stand
by listen here's what I'm doing I'm
betting on the fact that this is not the
end of the United States economy okay if
I'm wrong about that it's not going to
matter what I do with my money
okay but assuming that this is not the
end I am considering this an opportunity
to keep doing the buying of mutual funds
and bonds in the asset allocation that I
have been doing at a discount
it's very what else can I do right I
mean I'm not going to panic sell
typically dividends don't decline
drastically during downturns if at all
which means that those dividends while
stocks are cheaper will get you slightly
more additional shares so that then when
things eventually recover you have more
shares on which you can gain that's what
I'm doing I'm not shorting I'm not doing
any of that stuff
that that's my view it's a long-term
approach for the last 15 years I've been
just accumulating shares in in the asset
allocation that makes sense to me period
yeah that's all and that's not advice
for anybody in particular let me say
thank you and welcome to Trevor kodesh
who is new member number 10 today Thank
You Trevor appreciate your support
Matthew Tremblay is new member number 11
today I want to say thanks to Matthew as
well very much appreciate your support
at join pakman.com yeah I am NOT I don't
believe that I am
smart enough to time the market right so
you know people say dude there's still
plenty of time to short it or just sell
and then buy back and lower I don't
think I'm smart enough to do that I just
don't when I type toyed with stocks when
I was younger rarely did that stuff work
for me I don't believe I'm smart enough
to do that so my goal is hold stocks for
as long as possible every additional day
I own a stock as an additional day on
which I can accumulate a dividend on
that stock and when I buy which I'm
continuing to do I'm doing it at lower
prices that's it that I don't have any
there's nothing special that that I'm
doing beyond that okay Lance Power says
David what are the stakes for this
speech can Trump salvage this Oh hold on
a second I had a big scroll there I have
no idea I don't I don't pretend to know
what's going to happen after Donald
Trump announces an emergency engine just
minutes from now I started accumulating
index funds when I was around 20 okay
skunk games just wait until this hits a
homeless population in a major city
universal health care anyone well that's
it that's a case a lot of people are
making and it's a reasonable one the
dude says relating to your story the
City of Boerne Gamow in northern Italy
is basically ground zero for coronavirus
and has a funeral every 30 minutes yeah
that's I mean I didn't I didn't want to
say but that's that's where our friend
is he lives in Bergamo D Smitty says the
province of Saskatchewan in Canada may
have a tentative vaccine for the virus
let me google that Saskatchewan
coronavirus vaccine all I'm seeing is
that they got a grant to find a vaccine
I'm not seeing anything else right now
but if somebody has other articles I I
plan to to look into that yeah I don't
know I don't have any other details on
that as of yet
Zachary Snyder says David you should
watch the Rogen episode with Michael
osterholm I did and I recommend that to
people as well okay so three
recommendations to people right now if
you want to get information from actual
medical experts number one check out dr.
Dena Grayson on Twitter teller David
Pakman sent you if you follow her I
would appreciate that because we're
trying to get her on the show number two
check out dr. John Campbell's
Tube channel he's doing daily or twice
daily updates and number three check out
the Michael osterholm episode with Joe
Rogan named wood held who do we believe
Trump or Trump he says everything's fine
but is also declaring a state of
emergency and maybe even martial law no
evidence yet that he is declaring
Martial Law
Lawrence Burris has grabbed a youtube
subscription Joseph van Scoy says the
fatality rate is likely around one
percent assuming a third of the people
need hospitalization Harvard model
assume assumes infection of 75 to 150
million in the US depending on
intervention yes indeed that is that is
exactly what I am reading and I just
missed a call from Sam cedar Sam cedar
interesting I'm gonna have to talk to
him a little bit later
let excuse me folks news is breaking let
me just tell Sam hold on hey I'm
streaming can I call you back
something's going on with Sam cedar who
knows and hope that my phone just picked
that up as well Sam clearly needing to
talk to me about something and I don't
think it would be appropriate for the
livestream okay Mohamed Pope says what's
your advice regarding going to the gym
listen I don't know I I have been going
to the gym up until days ago and I'm not
going anymore partially because I've had
a little bit of a cough and partially
because it seems that it's it's just a
ripe place for contagion so I'm not
going to the gym at this point in time
Scott white says chloroquine is a
malaria treatment that has shown
possible efficacy in SARS CoV to C
PubMed article PubMed three to zero okay
very good so we will google that I
appreciate that very very much and we
are just waiting here PubMed com we have
that this is exactly of the type of
information that is useful very good
okay Aaron bolio says I've had a really
bad cough for the last week I'm 24 not
worried but trying to be careful around
parents in their 60s yeah I'm staying
away from my parents
Peyman a Lemmy
and jkc have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions name withheld says not to
be morbid but maybe Tulsi is taking all
this into consideration what if burnt
Biden and Bernie get the virus she could
be the default candidate no comment but
you know people clearly are aware of the
demographic realities of this of what's
going on here let's see what Sam wanted
oh yeah sorry ok yeah so we don't know
what Sam wants but Sam needs something
could trump be stalling for the markets
to close I don't that's an interesting
question if Trump's can if Trump can
stall this speech until the market
closes maybe up four percent in only
forty three minutes
maybe whatever disastrous news he's
about to deliver including possibly the
complete and total shutdown of is trump
going to recommend all restaurants
closed I mean what what Trump is going
to announce whenever he speaks could
potentially have a year or longer of
impact on the economy so it's possible
that that's what Trump is doing
Cristobal Moreno has grabbed a youtube
subscription Anthony McGary says why
can't the right seat Trump's constant
lying I don't know I don't know but it's
really really bad let's see here
okay other okay I want to thank a few
people who signed up on my website Tyler
dang has signed up and his new member
number 12 at join pakman.com John Luke
Gutierrez is new member number 13
Scott Hilliard is new member number 14
at join pakman.com Justin Boley is new
member number 15 today Rudy Trujillo is
new member number 16 today and that's it
really appreciate your support at join
pakman.com we are 18 minutes past when
Donald Trump was supposed to speak I
don't want to start searching around but
does anybody have any update as to what
this delay has been caused by do we know
what what is causing this this delay or
do we not know let me see what's
happening on PBS PBS Trump coronavirus
let's see PBS
live we don't have that here let's see
live now I can't even find the live PBS
stream does anybody know what's going on
is this entire thing been canceled
waking waiting for markets to close he's
busy making money yeah we don't know
there's some kind of delay it's not
clear what's going on I don't know Chris
Brown what effect if any has the virus
been shown to have on otherwise healthy
young adults who vape regularly I don't
know anything about vaping but what so
let me give you the the vaping and
smoking is it is an interesting question
again I'm being very very careful
oh wait somebody says that there's a
live feed of the room if somebody tells
me where to find a live feed of the room
in which they're gonna give the remarks
I would I would pull that up other
channels have audio and NPR Twitter has
a live feed if someone can describe a
YouTube channel that I can find then I
will pull that up NBC News NPR okay
let's try to find the NBC news one okay
NBC News Trump coronavirus let's see
here
special report here it is okay all right
very good so we'll keep it here and this
will let us know exactly when it's when
it's starting okay listen so early on
and again I want to be really clear I'm
not an expert on this I'm just reading
about it and when I see a trustworthy
source I tell you what I've read early
on Wuhan and Hubei Province had a very
high death rate and there were way more
men dying than women why was that okay
there is the idea that for cultural
reasons many more men smoked in China
than women and that this really is
interacting with people with any kind of
respiratory liability including what
smoking does to you and that could
explain why so many why the death rate
what why so many more men and the death
rate was higher for men than women
early in China okay that's one met one
expert that suggested that so I have
been saying for years I wouldn't be
vaping I wouldn't be smoking banana leaf
ingesting smoke you know when when they
say the term of vapor people think oh
it's like steam it's like water steam
it's like but it's like a steam bath
know what vapor really means is
aerosolized vaping chemicals I wouldn't
want that stuff in my lungs and I
wouldn't be doing it and I wouldn't be
surprised if young people who do vape
are more at risk of developing
complications that that's my advice just
based on what I've read
Rick Noonan ascends a super jet clever
to swear did Trump really clarify oops
sorry
where was that one did Trump clarify his
waving off co-pays for coronavirus
treatment statement no but some
governor's actually got insurance
companies to make good on it gadi bag
for Lee has grabbed the YouTube
membership SC John has subscribed
phylogeny says chloroquine is an
ionophore that increases intracellular
zinc concentrations and zinc inhibits
SARS in vitro it's being used in Korea
with promising results but there is yet
no confirming double-blind testing that
is a very specific analysis which I
appreciate lady of the lake I called the
doctor with the flu Monday I'm in
Washington was not asked where I live
where I caught it or next step I would
have thought they'd be trying to gather
data the systems are failing us sadly a
lot of these systems are not are not
working well and I wish that the
situation was different welcome if
you're just joining us on Twitch oh you
are a big part of what we are doing here
and you have been I want to say thank
you to Sam as a balm for grabbing a
twitch Prime subscription and wants me
to call Sam cedar on stream Rose API one
five one seven has subscribed with prime
laughing Virgil has subscribed with
prime zipper has a subscription as well
I appreciate that if you're just joining
on YouTube I really appreciate you being
here we are standing by for Donald Trump
I would really appreciate it if you're
watching on YouTube
if you
the like button and the subscribe button
these these things are all free we plan
to continue of bringing you all of
what's going on with the virus and the
expected national emergency and you can
really help us out just by hitting like
and subscribe it takes just a second and
it really does do a lot for our channel
that that's not a joke okay let's see
here Zachary Snyder if people don't know
they can help by installing folding at
home org to donate their computers idle
resources to help research on the virus
yeah I'm familiar with that website
Toby Schweiger has grabbed a youtube
subscription clever to swear says 2600
were affected by corona virus in Italy
yesterday today's about 2500 it is a
decrease we're all safe now great we
fixed it guys it's all good vicious RK
do you think getting a gun is a smart
idea as part of preparation if not is
there any point where it would be a good
idea I would be lying to you if I said
when I start thinking about we we don't
even have a national emergency yet
people are buying all the toilet paper
they can find people are buying 50-pound
bags of rice I worry that there will be
the potential for I want to be careful
erratic behavior and decisions once a
national emergency is declared I don't I
don't know I don't want to say anything
I don't want to give anybody any ideas
let me put it that way
captain Aiko says can you shout out
Benjamin Dixon when will he be on the
show next yes Benjamin Dixon doing great
work don't know when he will be on the
on the show next Travis hides has check
out Sam Harris's recent episodes as well
on the virus
Cynthia Muniz and Broderick ass bling as
well as Cheryl Mauro have grabbed
youtube subscriptions Mike says it's
weird in Austria on one hand you see
people like this lady I saw at a store
buying a hundred kilograms of sugar on
the other hand people say this is all BS
much love from Europe be safety we're
trying bran doe sends a super chat from
Mexico clever to swear says you know how
Italians kiss kiss each
to greet yeah I mean so do Argentinians
I don't know what's going on in my birth
country of Argentina
Jen's flock says what side are you using
to follow kovat numbers I'm mostly using
world ah meters dot info but there's
this other platform a RC G is calm which
is pretty good and has a lot of other
data it's the it's not all the same data
this is run by Johns Hopkins and I was
planning on looking at this with you
guys after Trump speaks but mostly I've
been using world ah meters and I like
how increasingly you can look at country
by countries so we can look for example
China's cases have drastically
diminished
thanks to their draconian measures if
oops sorry I clicked China again if you
look at Italy on the other hand you see
that daily cases in Italy are going in
the exact wrong direction that's not
good in fact that's very very bad if you
look at South Korea South Korea is a
country that has gotten this under
control
you do see declining cases although a
little bit of a burst recently so I find
rural da meters to be pretty good still
standing by for Donald Trump scheduled
to speak 26 minutes ago it is
conceivable that he is actually going to
wait all the way until the top of the
hour to prevent whatever he is about to
do including presumably declaring a
national emergency to prevent it from
immediately tanking the stock market in
that case it will likely just tank on
Monday unless something happens in the
interim to change that I want to say
thanks to a couple of other new members
Robert Boyd is new member number 17
today at join pakman.com Reed Steinmetz
is new member number 18 at join
pakman.com Manfredi sequi is new member
number 19 at join pakman.com thanks to
benjamin ledwell your subscriber number
20 today very much appreciate the
support and we we are you know I don't
care if we use this coupon code it saves
you 66 percent support at any level is
always very much appreciated okay we are
actually close to 10,000 live concurrent
viewers on YouTube we've
never had that before which is
incredible it's sad that it takes a
national tragedy to do that but I really
appreciate the community that that's
been following our coverage of
everything going on with coronavirus we
do currently have across our three
platforms somewhere around 12,000 people
in total who are watching but we are we
are incredibly getting dangerously close
to 10,000 live viewers on YouTube and we
have never had that so welcome to
everybody if you're new to the channel
and you're wondering who the hell is
that guy with the weird hair in the
bottom right of the screen this is the
david pakman show youtube channel and i
would love it if you liked our stream
and also hit the subscribe button
um these things cost nothing and it's
it's it's really a big deal for us and
and I appreciate that you guys are all
here and there it is 10,000 live
concurrent viewers on YouTube incredible
and nothing like a tragedy I guess to
bring people together and we are just
waiting here on Donald Trump and Recep
says my local AMC canceled all showings
just now listen it sucks but it's
responsible it's the responsible thing
to do McGahee
has subscribed on YouTube Christopher
hellström welcome Ori Stewart says
vaccine in testing stages insects cachi
Juan any thoughts there's a bunch of
vaccines that are in testing right now
there's uh yeah and that that's good
news although it's gonna be a while
don't Dan Hastert has grabbed a YouTube
subscription I appreciate that
where did Dan Hester go there is s Higgs
says Nick Fuentes on the show you
platform Tim Poole
oh my goodness get it get out of here or
roll us it is an uncomfortable reality
that a vote to Biden shows the DNC they
are correct but letting Trump win is
unacceptable yeah listen I mean we're
not doing really like political you know
handicapping of races but Joe Biden is
going to unless Joe Biden dies during
the debate on Sunday Joe Biden is going
to so crush Bernie Sanders on Tuesday
assuming that none of those elections
are postponed he is Florida Illinois
looked like it might
be a place Bernie had a shot Biden's
gonna crush them Ohio look like it might
be close by Daan's gonna crush them
iii-it's
it's gonna be great the numbers are
going to be crazy I expect you oh by
Denis be more than 2 million votes ahead
by the end of Tuesday x' elections it's
just the reality you know I know people
it's like I'm so past people getting mad
at me for telling the truth looks like
something's happening here comes Donald
Trump ladies and gentlemen here comes
Donald Trump and we will just watch it
over here the we don't know what to
expect I would prefer that okay here we
go this what we are about to hear will
tell us what is the next year of life in
the United States going to be like very
much everyone thank you thank you I'll
take notes
beautiful day in the Rose Garden
appreciate everybody being here today
I'd like to provide an update to the
American people on several decisive new
actions we're taking in our very
vigilant effort to combat and ultimately
defeat the I've got it all the way up
guys I'm sorry
fire virus he he sounds sort of bracket
very hard on this we've made tremendous
progress when you compare what we've
done to other areas of the world it's
it's pretty incredible let me get a
louder feed guys give me a second early
designation and the closing of the
borders then as you know Europe was just
designated as the hot spot right now and
we close that border while ago so that
was lucky or through talent or through
luck call or whatever you want but
through a very collective action and
shared sacrifice national determination
we will overcome the threat of the virus
I also announced Wednesday night
following the advice of our medical
professionals who are doing a tremendous
job and we appreciate it very much that
we're suspending the entry of foreign
nationals who have been to Europe in the
last 14 days watching stocks from
entering the United States citizens
permanent residents and our families any
of the families returning from Europe
will be subject to extra screening as
well as self isolation for a period of
14 days from census the World Health
Organization confirmed today many of the
things that what we said were 100
percent correct including our
designation before them of Europe like
our earlier very aggressive actions with
China this measure will save countless
lives
I appreciate a number of the folks
behind me a lot number the people behind
me said that that saved a lot of lives
that early designation but it is only
the beginning of what we're really doing
and now we're in a different phase we
had some very old and obsolete rules
that we had to live with it worked under
certain circumstances but not under mass
circumstances that inflating some time
they were in place for a long time and
we're breaking them down now and they're
very usable for certain instances but
not for this to unleash the full power
of the federal government that this
effort today I am officially declaring a
national emergency there it is
two very big words the action I am
taking will open up access to up to
fifty billion dollars of very
importantly very important and a large
amount of money for states and
territories and localities and our
shared fight against this disease in
furtherance of the order emerging every
state to set up emergency operation
centers effective immediately you're
going to be hearing from some of the
largest companies and greatest retailers
and medical companies in the world
they're standing right behind me on the
side of me I'm also asking every
hospital in this country to activate its
emergency preparedness plan so that they
can meet the needs of Americans
everywhere the hospitals are very
engaged New York and various other
places are also various engage I just
spoke with Governor Cuomo we had a very
good conversation and we're working very
strongly with many states including New
York the emergency orders I'm issuing
today will also confer broad new
authority to the Secretary of Health and
Human Services the Secretary of HHS will
be able to immediately waive provisions
of applicable laws and regulations to
give doctors hospital all hospitals and
health care providers maximum
flexibility to respond to the virus and
care for patients this includes the
following critical authorities the
our new way of law is to enable
telehealth a fairly new and incredible
thing that's happened and if in the
not-so-distant past I tell you what
they've done with telehealth is
incredible it's incredible
it gives remote doctors visits and
hospital check-ins the power to waive
certain federal license requirements so
that doctors from other states can
provide services and states with the
greatest need
number two the ability to waive
requirements that critical access
hospitals limit the number of beds to
twenty five and a length of stay to 96
hours the ability to waive the
requirements of a three day hospital
stay prior to admission to a nursing
home big thing the authority to waive
the rules to hinder hospitals ability to
bring additional physicians on board or
obtain needed office space they can do
as they want they can do what they have
to do they know what they have to do now
they don't have any problem getting it
done the authority to waive rules that
severely restrict where hospitals can
care for patients within the hospital
itself ensuring that the emergency
capacity can be quickly established will
remove or eliminate every obstacle
necessary to deliver our people the care
that they need and that they're entitled
to no resource will be spared nothing
whatsoever ten days ago I brought
together CEOs of commercial and said
this White House had directed them to
immediately begin working on a solution
to dramatically increase the
availability of tests other countries
have called us and worked with us and
they're doing similar things or will be
now as a result of that action today
we're announcing a new partnership with
private sector to vastly increase and
accelerate our capacity to test for the
coronavirus we want to make sure that
those who need a test can get a test
very
safely quickly and conveniently but we
don't want people to take a test if if
we feel that they shouldn't be doing it
and we don't want everyone running out
and taking only if you have certain
symptoms using federal emergency
authorities the FDA approved a new test
for the virus we did this within hours
after receiving the application from
Roche a process that would normally take
weeks we therefore expect up to a half a
million additional tests will be
available early next week we'll be
announcing locations probably on Sunday
night
I want to thank Roche great company for
their incredible work I'd also like to
thank thermo Fisher the FDA's goal is to
hopefully authorize the air application
within 24 hours it'll go very quickly
it's going very quickly which will bring
additionally 1.4 million tests on board
next week and five million within a
month I doubt we'll need anywhere near
that yeah at the same time we've been in
discussions over seas and retailers to
make drive through tests available in
the critical locations identified by
public health professionals the goal is
for individuals to be able to drive up
and be swamped without having to leave
your car I want to thank Google Google
is helping to develop a website it's
going to be very quickly done unlike
websites of the past to determine
whether a test is warranted and to
facilitate testing at a nearby
convenient location we have many many
locations behind us by the way we cover
the this country in a large parts of the
world by the way we're not going to be
talking about the world right now but we
cover very anyway what doesn't mean
somewhat totally our country bill parson
Obamacare every location Google has 1700
engineers working on this right now
they've made tremendous progress our
overriding goal is to stop the spread of
the virus and to help all Americans who
have been impacted by this
again we don't want everybody taking
this test it's totally unnecessary and
this will pass this will pass through
and we're gonna be even stronger for it
we've learned a lot you just pulled out
some notes tremendous amount has been
learned I want to thank deborah birx and
i want to ask her maybe to come up and
say a few words as to what's happening
dr. Burks is a highly respected person
I've gotten to know very well over the
last six days and yes someone who's very
old very old fashioned somewhat obsolete
certainly obsolete when it comes to the
kind of numbers that we're talking about
dr. Burks please someone who knows
something say say a little something and
everybody speaking and to be here with
all of you I think you know at the
beginning of this epidemic HHS through
CDC proactively developed an assay built
on the existing flu surveillance system
that surveillance system was then
converted to diagnostic system as I'm
just going to switch to a safer stream
oh god this one's too quiet our current
approach to testing was inadequate to
need to meet the needs of the American
public he asked for an entire overhaul
of the testing approach he immediately
called the private sector laboratories
to the White House as noted and charge
them with developing a high throughput
quality platform that can meet the needs
of the American public we are grateful
to LabCorp and quest for taking up the
charge immediately after the meeting and
within seventy now at 72 hours bringing
additional testing access particularly
to the outbreak areas of Washington
State and California and now across the
country we are also very grateful to the
universities in large hospital systems
that took up the charge developed their
own quality tests made available by new
new FDA guidance
this has resulted in expanded testing
across New York California Washington
Colorado and you see sometimes those
drive-thru options that have been made
available through these high throughput
options following the meeting last week
major commercial laboratory equipment
and diagnostic companies took immediate
action to adopt and develop new testing
systems last night the initial company
Roche received sta FDA approval moving
from request to development to approval
in record time this innovative approach
centered fully on unleashing the power
of the private sector focusing on
providing convenient testing to hundreds
of thousands of Americans within short
turnaround times in less than two weeks
together we have developed a solution
that we believe will meet the future
needs testing needs of Americans I
understand how difficult this has been I
was part of the hiv/aids response in the
80s we knew from died from first finding
cases in 1981 it took us to almost 1985
to have a test it took us another 11
years to have effective therapy it is
because of the lessons learned from that
that we were able to mobilize and bring
those individuals that were key to the
HIV response to this response I
understand that a lot of this
behind-the-scenes action over the last
couple of weeks was invisible to the
press and the American people but this
intense effort has not sorry the volume
is low let's go today solutions but an
automated high throughput system
bringing the availability of these
quality Korona viral testing to the
American people at unprecedented speed
finally I want you to know in South
Korea they did have a large number of
tests available over the last several
weeks their positivity rate is between
three and four percent with LabCorp and
quest expanded testing their positivity
rate is between one and two percent so
we want to also announce this new
approach to testing o which will start
in this
website up here facilitated by Google
where clients and patients and people
that interest can go fill out a
screening questionnaire move down for
symptoms or risk factors yes they would
move down this and be told where the
drive through options would be for them
to receive this test that labs will then
move to the high-throughput automated
machines to be able to provide results
in 24 to 36 hours that's Mercatus the
intent of this approach we have seen at
work just in our own United States and
we want to bring this across the
continent thank you very much
that's the right thing to do it should
have been done it six weeks ago right
I'd like to maybe have Tony do you want
to come up you become a yeah yeah I
think everybody out here notice you're
pretty well but tony has been doing he's
confident it's you have working long
long hours and you've seen a lot
happened but this has been it's pretty
great experience and working with you
has been terrific Tony please an actual
doctor who knows things thank you very
much mr. president
this is an example of another example of
what I've been referring to in my
discussions with many of you in the
audience as a proactive leaning forward
aggressive trying to stay ahead of the
curve and what you've seen now what it
is that we're going to be able to remove
the constraints so that people at the
state the local level the individual
physician all the way up through the
federal government will have as many
constraints as possible removed for them
to do everything they possibly can so
that we can implement the things that
we've been talking about the containment
the mitigation so that as I've said many
times that curve that I refer to that
goes up we don't want to have that curve
we want to suppress it down to that
small mound and I think what we've done
today is something that is going to be a
very important element in having us be
successful in doing that we still have a
long way to go there will be many more
cases but we'll take care of that and
ultimately as the president said this
will end but what's going on
today is going to help it to end sooner
than it would have thank you if I could
some of these folks we know they're
celebrities in their own right they're
the biggest business people the greatest
retailers oh dear God you were in the
world and one of them is Doug McMillon
from Walmart and I'd like to have Doug
if you would say a few words wherever
you may be the Walmart CEO gets to speak
when we got the call yesterday from the
White House we were eager to do our part
to help serve the country and given what
we're facing that's certainly important
to do we should all be doing that so
we've been asked to make portions of our
parking lot available in select
locations in the beginning and scaling
overtime as supply increases so that
people can experience the drive-through
experience that the president described
we'll stay involved and do everything we
can from a supply chain point of view to
be of assistance
thank you sir thank you very much
appreciate very much I'll just stay
right over here and Richard if you could
come up please Richard please
Walgreens thank you thank you mr.
president and similar to to Doug and
Walmart we're happy to stand in here and
help in communities all across America
because a lot of times when we have
natural disasters our stores are a
beacon in the community and this
situation is no different so we look
forward to partnering with the CDC the
administration HHS and the task force
and specifically to the vice president's
doing such a fantastic job we're ready
to engage in help thank you thank you
nobody's shaking oh they are similar
again that's not a good idea yes Brian
Cornell target everybody shaking hands
keep shaking it now trying to passes it
to him there you go now he's got it well
mr. president thank you for inviting us
here today along with our colleagues
from Walmart and Walgreens and our
partners at CVS normally you'd view us
as competitors but today we're focused
on a common competitor and that's the
feeding the spread of the coronavirus
and we look forward to working with the
administration to do our fair share to
alleviate this growing threat so thank
you for including us today in the near
term we're all committed to making sure
we're keeping our stores open to serve
the American consumer who's rapidly
stocking up on household essentials key
food and beverage items stocking up
during this
I'm making sure we run safe stores and
create an environment that's safe for
our team members with making sure that
they feel supported during this very
critical time so thank you for including
I see very much okay yep is Tom here Tom
Paula
Thank You mr. president as CEO of Becton
Dickinson were one of the leading
providers of medical devices as well as
collection products for testing of
coronavirus we were wrapping up our
manufacturing capacity to ensure that
the right collection devices and testing
equipment are ready to to address this
issue
Steve anybody's doing great Rock Kowski
and requests great job Diagnostics
please great job thank you for thank you
very much thank you mr. president so as
mentioned we recall the leadership of
the vice president last week to come
together as an industry and we took
advantage of that opportunity work with
the FDA to work with the Center for
Disease Control and we were up and
running with tests in a number of our
facilities as the president mentioned we
now have capabilities from Roche
Diagnostics that we will bring into our
facilities this weekend and I know
myself announced my colleague at lab
core will be doing the same so the
capacity available to the American
public to support this action with
consumers will be considerably increased
in the next few weeks Thank You mr.
Russell very much I appreciate it Thanks
and Matt sauce please have Roche sauce
Matt thank you man
Thank You mr. president so from Roche we
want to thank the FDA for their rapid
approval of our coronavirus tests we
really appreciate the partnership with
the CDC and the FDA to get that to
market as fast as possible market
because it's critical for us to make
that available to help patients in need
and working with laboratories to get it
up and going in the near future which
will bring hundreds of thousands of
tests available to patients in need in
the United States so thank you and you
can do it you can do it the great
company David Pierre of signify signify
health please thanks
Thank You mr. president we are the
largest house call provider in the US
and we go to the homes of the most
vulnerable elderly and through our
network and our logistics engine we
stand ready to help and provide our
clinicians to be where they're needed
whether they're in retail clinics or in
the home and we're here to assist thank
you very much we'll be changing a lot of
the rules regulations for future should
this happen in the future which we hope
it never does
Trump coronavirus we altered by Ace
Hardware out there
Walmart better ones over the years and I
guess that'll continue to an extent but
we hope it never happens but we're going
to be changing a lot of the old rules
and specifications and regulations Adam
Schecter who has really been of
tremendous help LabCorp please Adam
Thank You mr. president
and LabCorp we're working every second
of every day to increase the number of
tests that we can run we're working with
academic medical centers with our
colleagues at Quest with other hospital
and other laboratories to ensure that we
do everything we can to increase the
testing as we move forward and I can
tell you we understand how important the
testing is and we are committed to doing
everything possible Thank You Thomas
Moriarty
CBS CBS can't forget CBS Thank You Jose
Thank You mr. president
we're going to fly all the way I've been
focused since the start of making sure
our patients and the customers we serve
have the information they need the
safety they need as well we are
committed to working with the
administration and local public health
officials to make this work as well and
thank you sir for the honor are these
advertisers like what's going on
and Bruce Greenstein LHC Group
tremendously talented people thank you
very much mr. president thank you for
the honor being here and the home health
industry has been treating patients and
seniors and the safety and comfort of
their own home for decades I'm very
proud to be part of the equation for
testing in their own home for Americans
that can't get to a test site or live
rural areas far away from a retail
establishment we're here to help to
partner with our hospitals and
physicians as well as the people we have
here today that will be doing testing
around the country thank you okay I like
that that's good also announcing the
following emergency executive actions
today to help our students and their
families I've waved interest at all
student loans held by federal government
agencies and that will be until further
notice oh so we can't afford anything
for a lot of students that are left in
the middle right now many of those
schools have been closed based on the
price of oil I've also instructed the
Secretary of Energy to purchase that a
very good price large quantities of
crude oil for storage in the US
strategic reserve we're going to fill it
right up to the top saving the American
taxpayer billions and billions of
dollars helping the oil industry and
making us even further with that
wonderful goal which we've achieved
which nobody thought was possible of
energy independence it puts us in a
position that's very strong and we're
buying it at the right price and that's
something that would have not even been
possible a week ago the price of oil
went down quite a bit so we're gonna
fill it up there's a good time to fill
it up I'd like to ask Mike Pence to say
a few words boy that's not going to be
maybe lead us in prayer Thank You mr.
president
it is this day should be an inspiration
to every American oh oh because thanks
to your leadership from early on not
only are we bringing a
whole-of-government approach to
confronting the coronavirus industry -
we're bringing in all of America
approach mr. president from early on you
took decisive action you suspended all
travel from China you created travel
advisories South Korea in Italy we
screened all travelers from all airports
in both of those countries that's a
potent on the unanimous recommendation
of your health experts you
at midnight tonight we'll effectively
suspend all travel from Europe and
Americans that were returning will be
screened and asked to voluntarily
participate in a 14-day quarantine
throughout this process mr. president
you put the health of America first but
you brought the best of America to
address it and it's not just at the
federal level Wow she said mr. president
we've been working with states across
the guidelines from CDC for every
American but this week at your direction
we tailored specific recommendations
from CDC for New York Washington state
California Massachusetts in Florida and
we're in continuous contact as you said
with governor's around the country mr.
president you have forged a seamless
partnership with every state in every
territory in this country to put the
health of our nation first and you
imagine but today I trusted people
around the country that are looking on
at this extraordinary public and private
partnership to address the issue of
testing with particular inspiration
after you tapped me to lead the taps
White House Corona task force mr.
president you said this is all hands on
deck and you directed us to immediately
reach out to the American business
sector commercial labs to meet what we
knew then would be the need for testing
across the spectrum and today with this
historic public-private partnership we
have laid the foundation to meet that
need
I've never seen anything for Americans
looking on by this Sunday evening we'll
be able to give specific guidance on a
on when the website will be available
you can go to the website as the
president said you'll type in your
symptoms and be given Direction whether
or not a test is indicated and then at
the same website you'll be directed to
one of these incredible companies that
are going to give a little bit of their
parking lot so the Dow would combine do
a drive-by test mr. president I want to
join you in thanking Walmart and CVS and
Target oh yeah I mean these are
companies that are synonymous with
communities large and small where people
come together and now they're going to
come together to meet the needs of the
American public
these commercial laboratories LabCorp
and quest and Roche just done an
incredible job stepping forward and
they're gonna literally make literally
make a ton of money hundreds of
thousands of tests available and being
processed with results to patients in
the very near future
but it's all a result of you tasking us
with bringing together
godless government resources which all
state labs can now test across the
country CDC is testing but you said mr.
president that we wanted to bring all
the resources the country together and
that's what this partnership really
means you know truth is that we have
coronavirus cases now in 46 American
states virus and while the risk of
serious illness of the corona virus
remains low we want to encourage every
American to practice common sense
practice good hygiene go to the CDC's
website to see what the guidance is for
your community or for the American
people broadly and as the president has
said it's especially important now that
we look after a senior citizens with
chronic underlying health conditions
last week the president directed the
Center for Medicaid and Medicare
services to raise the standards at our
nursing homes increase inspections at
our nursing homes and today we're
offering very specific guidance which
Seema Verma will articulate about
visitations at nursing homes it's
important to remember that they were
there for us when we were growing up mr.
president this is crazy they helped us
with our homework they tucked us in at
night they cheered us on now she's
getting sued ablation Bolden is on in
our careers and now it's time for us to
be there for them and to recognize that
seniors with chronic health conditions
are the most vulnerable and Americans
can make a difference so wash your hands
use common sense look after the most
vulnerable and mr. president I know I
join you in saying that every American
should be proud why it's about you even
your front is 80 years right a
partnership that's going to be speeding
access of testing - well you could just
off Americans stand together as you've
said many times together we'll go
through this together
the health of America first Seba where's
Seba like you look at the Dow it's just
a bi friend that a step further oh well
thank you to the president for the
Declaration it allows my agency CMS that
runs Medicare and Medicaid and has
oversight of all of the nation's health
care facilities to suspend regulations
that could get in the way of treating
patients during this time these
temporary national blanket waivers are
reserved for the rarest of circumstances
and they represent a massive
mobilization of our country's resources
to combat this terrible virus and the
flexibilities we are offering will be a
god-sent to the providers clinicians and
facilities on the frontlines of this
fight from books jag and later CMS is
going to be issuing guidance directing
nursing homes to temporarily restrict
all visitors and non-essential personnel
with a few exceptions such as end of
life situations we fully appreciate that
this measure represents a severe trial
for residents of nursing homes and those
who love them but we are doing what we
must to protect our vulnerable elderly
thank you look at the market it's up
down it's crazy my address to the nation
the other night all Americans have a
role to play in defeating this virus
up it goes again our most effective
weapon right now is to limit the damage
to our people and our country 9% and
slow the spread of the virus itself the
choice we make the precautions we put
into place are critical to overcoming
the virus reducing its spread and
shortening the duration of the pandemic
which is what it is the CDC has
published guidelines and now he admits a
corona virus that gov to enable its
coronavirus gov got and it's very ly
very heavily used right now I will say
to enable every American to respond to
this epidemic and to protect themselves
their families and their communities and
there are the restrooms the young and
healthy Americans remains very low we've
learned a lot about this over the last
two weeks Wow anyone can be a carrier
for the virus and risk transmission to
older Americans and those with
underlying health conditions and those
who are most at risk they have not done
very well
older Americans who are especially if
they have a health problem they have not
done well we must take all precautions
and be responsible for the actions that
we take and that we see other people
take what a day we want to prevent the
spread and transmission of the disease
it's incredible what's sports what's
happening with the sporting world we're
ports so many of the great sports that
we've gotten so used to at this time of
the year they're not going to be meaning
and they've done it well look at the
night service actually but that would be
another way that it could be problems
could be caused but this is why I
outlined on Wednesday night my admission
administration's the fact that we've
issued a requirement suspending all
medically unnecessary visits to various
places but in particular nursing homes
we should all be working off the same
playbook when it comes to protecting
Americans we have to kind of need to be
consistent in adopting measures to limit
the spread of the virus the virus is the
same whether it's spreading in cities
towns or rural communities the tools and
tactics for attacking it are similar no
matter where you go you know I don't way
you go you have some hot spots
throughout the world right now that
people would have never thought possible
and they're being very seriously
affected the key among these efforts are
breaking chains of transmission between
people these measures have been adopted
by many companies universities and
schools and we want to protect the
safety and the health of their employees
and their students I encourage everyone
to follow the guidelines we've issued by
CDC and these
common-sense measures a lot of it's
common sense right for the areas where
the virus is spreading the CDC is
advising communities to postpone large
gatherings postpone assemblies social
functions and sporting events stagger
recess and lunch for schools but aren't
canceled limit in person meetings
increased scheduled cleanings then
canceled work sponsored travel among
numerous other steps that can be taken
Americans are the strongest and most
resilient people on earth and in the
coming weeks we will all have to make
changes and sacrifices but these
short-term sacrifices will produce
long-term gain and again I've said we're
learning a lot for the future and future
problems like this or worse it's getting
worse could get worse the next eight
weeks are critical we can learn and we
will turn a corner on this virus some
doctors say it will wash through it will
flow through and interesting terms and
very accurate I think you're gonna find
in a number of weeks it's going to be a
very accurate term in times of hardship
the true character of America always
shines through we live in the company of
the greatest heroes and the most
inspiring citizens anywhere in the world
we want to take care of our people we
want to draw on the strength of our
history drawing the strength of our
people and we will get through this all
together we will just get through it
so much progress has already been made
how inspiring and frankly the numbers
because the steps that have been taken
or at a level that a lot of people are
surprised no one's especially when
you're president I've added it with
other places with far smaller
populations the spirit in the will of
our nation is unbreakable we will defeat
this threat when America's tested
America rises to the occasion and to
those families and citizens who are
worried and concerned for themselves and
their loved ones I want you to know that
your federal government will unleash
every authority we
surcin tool in its disposal the
government I regard the lives and health
of our people will save you so we're
with you every step of the way no nation
is more prepared or more equipped to
face down this crisis as you know we a
rated number one in the world we're also
helping other nations Agent number one
many other nations were helping them a
lot and they're doing okay in some cases
in some cases they're not doing well at
all
but we're working with a lot of groups
of people and a lot of other nations
with faith in heart and hope and love
and determination we will succeed we
will prevail we will be very very
successful and we'll learn for the
future
we're number one which if you have any
questions we can take so go ahead please
and if you'd like to ask some of the
folks up here would be fine please mr.
president where are you with the House
bill yesterday we talked to you in the
Oval Office you were opposed to it what
has happened since then and and what's
the holdup on that well we just don't
think they're giving enough we don't
think the Democrats are giving enough of
God negotiating we thought we had
something but all of a sudden they
didn't agree to certain things that they
agreed to so we could have something but
we don't think they're giving enough
they're not they're not doing what's
right for the country and if I could ask
doctor foul sure go ahead please Thank
You mr. president you just mentioned
waiving interest for student loans you
talked about buying oil from the spar or
adding to the SPR what other specific
targeted and measures is your
administration thinking about taking the
Treasury secretary Stephen douching said
today that you're just in the second
inning of use that you might be undergo
that's true and we are looking at many
different things as you know you know
some of them they've been written about
very widely but we're gonna be releasing
a paper in about two hours
stating quite a few other steps in
really important ways please go ahead
paper will be clean please thank you so
much mr. president
I wonder I want to know if you are in
contact with the Brazilian president
both senado after a member of his
delegation who was with you Saturday was
tested positive and also senator I want
to ask another question if you let me
senators Lindsey Graham and also Senator
Scott Rick Scott are self isolating are
you planning to take any kind of
precursor any precautionary measures
detect you and also who was there no we
have no symptoms whatsoever and we have
we had a great meeting with the
president of Brazil Paulson our oh great
guy whatever the very tremendous he's
done he's doing a fantastic job for
Brazil oh yeah and as you know he tested
negative meaning nothing wrong this work
that thing work too because we did have
dinner with him
we were sitting next to each other for a
long period we shared frogs are you in
contact with him over the coronavirus we
have we're talking about it country to
country but we did discuss if he had a
problem it was reported that he may have
it and he doesn't fortunately much mr.
president
doctor foutch she said earlier this week
that the lag in testing was in fact a
failing do you take responsibility for
that no when can you guarantee that
every single American who needs a test
will be able to have a test what's the
date of now yeah no I don't take
responsibility at all because having a
set of circumstances and we were given
rules regulations and specifications
from a different time
was it meant for this kind of an event
with the kind of numbers that we're
talking about and what we've done is
redesigned it very quickly with the help
of the people behind me and we're now in
very very strong shape I think we'll be
announcing as I said Sunday night and
this will start very quickly and we have
will have the ability to do in the
millions give us two days for the period
of time so no and what we have done and
we are going to be leaving a very
indelible print for the future in case
something like this happens again but it
was a and that's not the fault of
anybody and frankly the old system
worked very well for smaller numbers
much smaller numbers but not for these
kind of numbers Tony maybe you'd like to
say something
yes please by Sunday night will every
American be able to get a test so just
to reiterate what I said to many of you
multiple times it's a distant of a
system the system was not designed for
what it was designed for it worked very
well
the CDC designed a good system if you
want to get the kind of blanket testing
and availability that anybody can get it
or you could even do surveillance to
find out what the penetrance is you have
to embrace the private sector and this
is exactly what you're seeing because
you can't do it without it so when I
said that I meant the system was not
designed for what we need now looking
forward the system will take care of it
right mr. president and interestingly if
you go back please if you go back to
shush the swine flu it was nothing like
this they didn't do testing like this
and actually they had lost approximately
14,000 people and they didn't do the
testing they started I think at about
testing when it was far too late what
we've done and one of the reasons I
think people are respecting what we've
done we've done it very early we've
gotten it very early and we've also kept
a lot of people out administration said
that they had tested a million people at
this point you will ask them how they
did with the swine flu is a disaster
thank you next place they had a very big
failure with swine flu a very big
failure president I want to ask you
about the European travel ban that goes
into effect at midnight tonight and the
exemption that you've offered to the UK
there are 17 countries that are in the
so-called Schengen zone that have fewer
coronavirus cases than the UK and just
in the past 24 hours the UK has added
208 coronavirus cases to their total why
do they mr. president deserve an
exemption well because I have those that
are adding them to this travel ban list
well that was recommended to me by a
group of professionals and we are
looking at it based on the new numbers
that are coming out and we may have to
include them in the list of countries
that we will you could say ban or
whatever it is during this period of
different ban but yeah the numbers have
gone up fairly precipitously over the
last 24 hours so
we may be adding that and we may be
adding a couple of others and we may
frankly start thinking about taking some
off Thank You mr. president
I'm not corresponding with hong kong
phoenix TV um you have been mentioned
you have mentioned that number in china
has been decreasing in china has made
tremendous progress in the past weeks
I'm wondering how much confidence does
this give you to control the virus in
the United States and do you see the
data China has been sharing with the
United States has been helpful I think
it has been helpful we've been working
very much with China
I've spoken as you know with President
Xi they went through hell and their
numbers are starting to look very good
they're really they're really looking
very good we're very happy about that
and we are sharing data yes in fact
we're sharing quite a bit of data
including the fact that some of our
pharmaceutical companies are working
over there right down with large groups
of people data yeah go ahead please
Thank You mr. president you spoke with
Canadian Prime Minister Trudeau
yesterday did you discuss the potential
closing of the border between the Canada
and the US and by extension
are you considering ways to salvage the
two billion dollar daily trade between
the two countries so we didn't discuss
the border we've had a very good
relationship just about finished with
the US by the way guys everybody's
spitting on to that same mic getting
passed around I think that was the
primary reason for the call at the time
his wife had not been diagnosed and
she's a lovely lady
wonderful lady great lady and very since
then I've heard read that the result was
that she has it and there was a little
surprise I think he was surprised also
we did discuss it prior to she's going
to be fine but he thought that she would
not most likely have the virus
unfortunately she does people we didn't
discuss the border yesterday don't
go ahead please if you have any
questions for these great geniuses up
here you should be even a business
question related to what we're talking
about
mr. president Ross Palumbo from ABC News
Miami is a relatively new Floridian what
is your message today to the cruise line
industry in the tribal industry that
that's sorted appends upon and since
senator rick Scott and miami-dade Mayor
Carlos Gimenez have the same exposure as
you and they ourself I like isolating
why what's your message to them that
they shouldn't be well I don't know that
I had exposure but I don't have any of
the symptoms and we do have a White
House doctor and I should say many White
House doctors too frankly and I ask you
many same question and they said you
don't have any symptoms whatsoever and
we don't want people without symptoms to
go and do the tests the test is not
insignificant as far as the cruise line
business we're with them all the way
it's a great business it's a great US
business frankly and I know how
important they are to the country that
includes Airlines but the cruise line
business obviously was hit very hard we
had a tremendous success out in Oakland
where we moved at vice president pence
did a fantastic job with that we worked
with UK we worked with Canada that don't
took there was a real people back in
Canada is approximately 600 people UK
likewise took a large number of people
back to the United Kingdom and we have
people quarantined it was a big
operation and worked out really you
don't hear about it anymore works very
well Mike you may even want to say
something about that because that was
really done properly well thank you mr.
president and that that that program
with the grand princess the ship is
continuing to be administered in the
highest standards orderly way as the
president directed and Americans that
needed treatment have received them I
spoke to the governor of Iowa today and
some of those who now have been cleared
are are able in proper supervision to be
returning to Iowa they're making
arrangements for them to do that others
in Texas others in Georgia again it's
another example of the extraordinary
cooperation governor
abbit governor Gavin Newsom governor
Bryant Kim of Georgia but to add to that
the president directed me last Saturday
to travel down to Miami we met with all
the leaders of the cruise line industry
great fun when the be several cruise
lines have announced a 60-day pause in
operations our Department of Homeland
Security has praised them for doing that
because of the unique health challenges
particularly presented to seniors with
underlying conditions we have a proposal
from the cruise line industry but
they're currently considering what other
steps that they might take perhaps even
similar to what those other lines have
taken we're anticipating some response
on that in the next 24 hours but as the
president said the American people
cherish our cruise line industry men and
women who work on the ships and women
who work on the shore all the economies
that are so benefited by a vibrant
cruise line industry and what the
president's directed us to do is whether
there whether there is a pause in the
moment as some Cruise Lines are doing
and as we all continue to discuss we
want to work with the cruise line
industry to ensure that when we come
through this that cruise lines and the
medical services that are available and
for the passengers and and all of the
crew that the cruise lines are safer
than ever before and can prosper for
many years to come
Trump's gonna cruise soon go ahead
please this question is for doctors a
foul she and Burke Burke's doctor foul a
based on what you currently know what is
the trajectory for when this outbreak
will peak how long will the American
people have to remain on this emergency
footing and for dr. Burks as the
administration tries to get its arms
around this testkit shortage issue the
next glaring need could be respirators
and related hospital equipment so what
does the administration doing right now
to ramp up production of respirator
great question and that kind of
equipment should this outbreak
persistent
so when you have an outbreak like this
particularly if you're trying to
interfere with it it's really impossible
to predict the time element of when it's
gonna peak and when it's naturally going
to go down so if you look at the
situation where countries really did not
get to the point of trying to contain
and mitigate very well you see a peak
over several weeks and then down again
over other several weeks what we're
trying to do with the efforts that we're
doing is to blunt that peak and I
mentioned that many times and I think
it's important and appropriate for me to
mention it again because it answers your
question when you talk about preventing
infections from without in which is the
kind of travel restrictions we're
talking about then how do you handle
what you already have in your country
yes you continue some sort of
containment but you also do mitigation
and you try to proportionate to the
areas where there are the most
infections the success of that and how
much you make this turn into this is
going to give you the amount of time if
we're successful it'll be less if we're
not successful it's gonna be more but
these kind of things generally run out
in a few months hopefully we'll make it
several weeks eight nine whatever we
expense what I tell you a number because
it depends on how successful we are
great thank you it's a great question
and dr. Falchi and I've worked together
a very long time and continue it's a
privilege to work with them every day so
I think you can learn very and I
appreciate there was some graphics done
by some of the reporting over the last
several days if you align the data from
China with the data with South Korea you
can start to see as to complete overlay
of that data and so that's what we're
tracking very closely as well as Italy
but you have an excellent question I
just want to make one note in South
Korea I want to repeat only 4% of the
tests were positive that means 96% of
the people had a different respiratory
disease because we're in the middle of
flu season cold season and all of the
other respiratory diseases that we get
every day in LabCorp inquests early data
they're running about 1 to 2 percent
pause
that means that we have a lot more other
respiratory disease out there besides
the corona virus and that's why the
screening is critical but even with the
screening we're gonna reload run what we
think are very low rates
needless to say though we're taking
extraordinarily seriously to plan for
what could come not what dot what doctor
felt you talked about blunting the curve
that makes it much less high need at
that peak of the curve that we're all
planning for so we're in full inventory
of all of our assets by the president
unlocking and this emergency order and
the Secretary of HHS is ability it
unlocks all of those stockpiles those
needs what the VA has what the DoD has
what the National Guard has and what
every hospital has and the hospital
emergency preparedness plan allows them
to defer elective issues to keep those
hospital beds open for those who might
need it so we're in full planning mode
for each of those things and I might add
that we are in the process and in some
cases have already done it ordered a
large number of respirators just in case
we hope we don't need them but we've
ordered a large number yeah guy please
thank you very much mr. president in
your speech to the nation
you mentioned the situation in China and
South Korea have improved and you're
thinking about remove the restrictions
also the warning right in place right
now when can we expect that announcement
and how do you see the overall progress
that asian countries made well some are
making progress some are not as you know
but some are making progress and as they
make progress as they get down to the
number that we all think is right that
they know is right we know is right
we'll be opening it up and some are
really moving along rapidly we hope to
be able to open things up as quickly as
possible a little talk about dating
I'd like to ask secretary czar and dr.
Foust
Fozzy couch just how dr. foul chee okay
all right better not a hundred percent
but 90 percent this affects the elderly
primarily and in that sense it's an
unusual disease is what the somatic
research done as to why it affects our
senior citizens more than others so I I
don't mean to to diminish your your
question but we already know why it
would affect senior citizens more
because when you talk about anything
that requires a robust immune system as
you get older your immune system is not
as potent as it is when you are young
and that's the reason why when you talk
about even influenza which we have
extraordinary experience with over
decades and decades the people who are
very vulnerable are the elderly and
those with underlying conditions the
same thing holds true for a variety of
other disease why cancer is more
prevalent in some in mostly in older
individuals of course the immune system
that screens for it is less robust so
what really is something that is kind of
well known over a lot of studies oh and
one of the questions was to a czar oh
yeah oh my god
the officials are expressing some tones
of discontent with how we're the source
of this virus has come from and they're
spinning some odd narratives what are
your response to the Chinese these are
the crazy crazy the box oh and have they
signaled any kind of resistance to
upcoming trade talks in in response to
deal with China they're gonna be buying
two hundred and fifty billion dollars
worth of goods and fifty billion from
our farmers and it's a great deal for
our country it's about time somebody did
that and frankly phase two will
start negotiating I did read one article
but I don't think that article was
representative certainly not of my
conversations with President Xi and they
know where it came from we all know
where it came from
Thank You mr. president you Michel
thunder from PBS newshour
my first question is you said that you
don't take responsibility but you did
disband the White House pandemic office
and the officials that were working in
that office left this administration
abruptly so what responsibilities do you
take to that and the officials that
worked in that office said that you that
the White House lost valuable time
because that office wasn't you defended
what do you make of that love it well I
just think it's a nasty question because
what I've done is and Tony had said we
saved thousands of lives because of the
quick closing and when you say me I
didn't do it we have a group of people I
could I could ask for apps by
administration but I could perhaps ask
Tony about that because I don't know
anything about it I mean you say you say
we did that I don't know anything about
it you don't know spending ministration
perhaps they do that you know people let
people go you used to be with a
different newspaper than you are now you
know things like that happened a great
job let me tell you these professionals
may be in these Aluna these great
incredible doctors and business people
the best in the world and I can say that
whether it's retailers or or labs or
anything you want to say these are the
best of the world we're doing a great
job
that is weapon we have 40 people right
now 40 compare that with other countries
that have many many times that amount
now one of the reasons we have 40 and
others have and again that number is
going up just so you understand and a
number of cases which are very small
relatively speaking it's going up but
we've done a great job because we acted
quickly we acted early and there's
nothing we could have done that was
better than closing our borders to
highly infected areas please go ahead
thank you mr. president when I say at
least for ntn24 for a Latin American
country and also first pain Laura Thoren
antenna dress I would like to ask you
two very brief questions one M for how
long we're gonna have the
emergency them I mean the national
emergency and I hope not long but it's
there now and it gives tremendous powers
for things that we need tremendous power
actually and the Stafford Act and
various other things that were involved
with and have studied and memorized by
so many different ways and forms it
gives the kind of power that we need to
get rid of this virus guys he doesn't
really and I hope it was very long but
whatever it takes so for now we still
don't know for how long and I have
something very important I wanted to ask
you is like how do you think do you
really think it's essential coordinating
with other countries and learning from
the lessons that they already suffer
this nation countries of course like
China and South Korea but now recently
Italy and Spain that coordination done
very yeah we're in touch with Italy and
you know everybody talked at one it's a
country that we love we have tremendous
millions and millions of people
originally origins from Italy and we're
working with them they're in a very
orator and people from it probably
relatively speaking the toughest
position of all we're in touch with
everybody we're in touch with when I say
everybody we're in touch with many of
the countries that you know about that
you're writing about and they're calling
us asking for advice they're asking for
the advice of the people behind me
Italy's got a tough situation but
they're they're really great really
clamped down and I think they're gonna
see some very good results it's tough
what they did they really took their
medicine but they're going to see some
much better results yeah Jeff
thank you sir with regard to domestic
travel should Americans feel safe or
should Americans at all be traveling to
states such as Washington State New York
and other hotspots within this country
and a follow-up on Brazil you're asking
people who come back from America from
Europe Americans were coming back from
Europe to self quarantine for a couple
weeks you were in a picture with
somebody who now has coronavirus from
Brazil at mar-a-lago
how is that different well I'll tell you
first of all I'm not coming back from
someplace exposed we there was somebody
that they say has it I have no idea who
he is but I take pictures and it is very
literally seconds I don't know the
gentleman that we're talking about have
no idea who is I haven't seen the person
there's a picture of somebody but I take
sometimes hundreds of pictures a day and
that night I was taking hundreds of
pictures so I just dial now I did sit
with the president for probably two
hours but he's tested negative so that's
good it's just a matter of his good and
yep cut him out this I would say if you
stay home it's not bad it's not bad now
there are certain parts of the country
that are essentially have known zero
problem Washington's been very tough in
particular nursing home and Washington
the state of Washington has been very
tough it's been a big percentage of dude
what about your what he does with the
guys on each of the deaths as you know
very well and they all came from a very
a certain area unfortunately please go
ahead go ahead
okay thank you very much mr. president
cordelia Lynch Sky News you talk this
week about the UK doing a good job in
tackling coronavirus not anymore light
of the rising cases are you changing
your mind about that you also just spoke
about possible travel restrictions have
you discussed when they might be put in
place well in light of the results as we
discussed before a lot of the results
we're gonna be looking at it and I know
the the task force is looking at it very
strongly vice president everybody it was
looking good but they've the results
have been building up pretty rapidly so
will will be taking another look at that
yes absolutely probably thanks wrap
right mister president thank you I want
to first follow up on Jeff's question
because the person you were standing
next to whether you know who he is or
not right tested positive for
coronavirus dr. Falchi said this morning
if you stand next to somebody who tested
positive
you should self isolate and get a test
you say your White House doctor is
telling you
something different who should Americans
listen to right and my second I think
they have to listen to their doctors and
I think they shouldn't be jumping to get
the test unless it's a necessary
addition to their doctors and I mean I
don't know that I haven't seen the
picture somebody said there's a picture
with somebody taking a picture with me
but I haven't seen it are you being
selfish by not getting tested and
potentially why did say I wasn't going
to be tested are you going to be most
likely yeah not for that reason but
because I think I will do it anyway it's
fairly soon we're working on that we're
working out of schedule oh my goodness I
know there's been a lot of talk about
testing I just want to make sure we're
clear though because we've been hearing
from doctors who say as of today they
still can't get patients tested who need
a test so as of today can everyone who a
doctor once have tested get tested and
if not win that's been true for a while
but I'll let Mike one of the ends of
that yeah he wants to leave this light
of pens well as the president said and
dr. Falchi has articulated the nature of
our current system where the CDC has
samples sent and tests are perform or
State labs perform tests or in some
cases university and hospital labs
perform tests it's generally adequate
for infectious disease or for people
getting a diagnostic work done but given
the sheer scale of this the president
tasked us with bringing together this
extraordinary public and private
partnership today by some estimates when
you add all the labs together and today
the president made it possible for every
state in the country and their state
labs to authorize labs across their
state to do coronavirus testing we're
estimating somewhere between 15 and 20
thousand tests a day are able to be
performed but very soon
with the program that was announced
today Americans will be able to visit
one of the sites closest to them as
described on the website if they're
symptomatic if the questionnaire just a
quick note guys because he's just lying
we know the lie the the language of the
number of tests that could be done per
day is a vague thing just about the
number of tests that exist within our
borders if you actually go and you say
to a testing center how many tests is
your maximum capacity based on what you
have and how long they take very often
the numbers like 20 okay so that's what
matters rise lab can contact the state
lab and again every state lab in the
country can perform tests today but what
the president charged us with the
deception when I was tasked to take over
the White House coronavirus task force
asked was open up tests all across the
country president said a few days ago
that we made it clear that any American
that wanted to get a test would be able
clinically to get a test because I
literally heard from the governor of
Washington State who said the doctors in
Washington state were saying that if you
were only mildly symptomatic they would
not order a test and fortunately the
president directed CDC to clarify that
right now anyone in consultation with
their physician regardless of their
symptoms can request a test the quest
and their doctors will contact those
those agencies those labs in their state
but very soon and when they do they're
being told we're not doing the tests
these these drive insights and be able
to obtain and participate in a test
that's perfectly said I think just to
review what's 4-time about the testing
with LabCorp inquest I think many of you
have been to doctors office and seen the
little boxes outside what they do is
they deliver both the specimen
collection piece because remember it's a
nasal swab it's not a tube of blood so
they've delivered that to doctors
offices and hospitals and then they will
arrange to pick that up the important
piece in this all is they've gone from a
machine that may have a lower throughput
to the potential to have automated
extraction I know you don't want all
these details but it's really
key for the laboratory people it's an
automated extraction and the RNA that
then runs in an automated way on the
machine with no one touching it and the
result comes out at the other end so
sample two machine two results that cuts
out a lot of the manual pieces that were
happening that we're delaying the test
results and so with that what's the
timeline like from when you're tested to
when you get results like next week what
should people expect well with the prior
testing it was taking several days
because the test is slower we believe
with this test because of its throughput
that the testing can be from start
remember it has to transport to the
laboratory that will run it and then
we're hoping that all can be finished
within 24 hours which is very similar to
other tests that you receive today these
are not point-of-care tests we are
working on point-of-care tests but we
have to realize point-of-care tests take
six months or more to develop so we're
not waiting for those we're still
diagnosing this on nucleic acid so as an
antibody this is actually the antigen
the the actual virus in your nose that
were amplifying Wow I think you have to
remember though we're working very
closely with States and this you have a
smaller form and more targeted form of
government going in I would wrap it I
would like in New York where the
relationship is very good like gavin
newsom where he made some very
complimentary care that's California he
made some really complimentary comments
the other day about how we're working
together we worked on the ship together
but we worked on a lot of other things
together having to do with this and
we'll really the relationship that we
have I can't think of a bad relationship
we're helping them we're funding them in
some cases depending on what it is
you're talking about and we're all
working together very closely so we've
done really I think a tremendous job of
of teamwork trumping the different
states right one or two more and if you
have if you have questions for these
folks does anybody have a question for
the folks up here who has a question up
here you have okay go host if you have a
question go ahead
thank you I have one for you as well for
them because I was waiting for that guy
because I haven't heard this - them
first yes I will okay with regards to
the CEOs can you please tell us when you
expect to see items like hand sanitizer
that has been going out of stock very
quickly bad on the shelves and go -
there have been a lot of reports about
that and for You mr. president could you
talk about a potential bailout for the
cruise industry you would suggest that
could happen is that something you're
still looking at and how much would that
be well I didn't suggest that it could
happen but I could tell you it's an
industry that was very badly impacted by
what's going on with the virus and it's
a great industry it's a very important
industry and we will be helping them and
we will be helping the airline industry
if we have to assuming we have - so far
people have been asking but if they
should be asking will we want to make
sure our airline is very strong and then
one day and one day all of a sudden
wasn't looking so good interestingly
were just talking or soaking - Doug and
the numbers they're doing from the
retailing standpoint I guess because of
this your business is like the opposite
all of you have didn't you've been
selling a lot of a lot of stuff you want
to answer the question as to the hand
sanitizers specifically the areas where
we're seeing pressure in the supply
chain or surface cleaners cleaning
supplies paper goods in particular hand
sanitizer is going to be very difficult
to have a hundred percent in stock on
for some time we're still replenishing
it and shipping it but as soon as it's
the stores it's going that same things
true for the categories I just mentioned
so all the retailers be working hand in
hand with the suppliers to bring that to
the market as fast as we can what is
your advice though for Americans who are
seeking those items what is your advice
they're selling out online they're
selling out in the stores I think I
think this team has given you other
examples of what people can do to fight
back against this virus and you should
look at the entire list why
oh my god basically saying you're loose
I mean obviously it sounds very
simplistic but wash your hands as often
as you possibly can and I know you're
not always in a position to be able to
wash your hands
but wash them is as much as you can if
you don't have the the alcohol wipes try
and get them if you can't get them just
try as best as possible to do it I mean
you got to do the best you can well just
general preparedness you know you want
to wash your hands you want to keep
distance from people and if you're
around some guys I tweeted about how
crazy it is that one American uses
allowed at these things and one American
use and their anchors are going bonkers
on me on Twitter right now you should go
see what's going on not an effective
protection against getting the corona
virus there it's selling out but the
soap and water hot water soap 20 seconds
that's how you do it last question go
ahead no oh yeah behind you thank you
very much mr. president you have a great
team of course that's true my question
is mr. president are you happy from the
Chinese response what correctly really
told you what really happened those days
and second Prime Minister Modi or India
have closed borders until April 15th if
you have spoken with the Prime Minister
of India and if they have needed any
help and finally sir any message for the
small businesses because they are losing
some businesses because of this thank
you sir I like the small businesses the
Small Business Administration is now
stacked with money to help them and
we're going to make the money readily
available if they needed small
businesses we had a great time in India
there was an incredible two days and
he's a great friend of mine and he's a
friend of his people because he was
greeted incredibly warmly as was I in
that stadium I was an incredible event
and I loved being with him so just say
hello to him but we we talking about
everything we talked about far more than
just borders and as far as president she
likewise he's a friend of mine I believe
that we are dealing in good faith that
we just were
- as you know as I just said he we just
worked an incredible deal big deal one
of the biggest deals ever made of any
kind big even by the standards of some
of the people here the deal with China
but I think that they want to get to the
bottom of things also we're working our
drug companies our pharmaceutical
companies are working very closely with
China and with India as you know and
with all over the world and they're all
over the world these are magnificent
companies that are very very
knowledgeable and it's we're very lucky
to have them because I think you're
going to come up with whether it's
therapeutic or whether it's just help
helping getting better and then
ultimately a vaccine which takes a
little bit longer because of the test
periods and a couple of other reasons
you're gonna have it very quickly
because the great knowledge and they'll
have it very quickly they've made a
tremendous amount of progress thank you
all very much we appreciate it Thank You
Leah thank you very much all right
before you guys leave especially if
you're watching on YouTube please do hit
like and subscribe on your way out just
smash absolutely I want that like and
subscribe button destroy it on your way
out I know a lot of people will be
tuning out now but we do really depend
on people who just come on by whether or
not you're trolling either way we do
always suggest like and subscribe
because it really does help us okay so a
lot of things going on here obviously
and I mean listen the takeaway from
listening to the letter of what Donald
Trump said is that he's doing everything
great everybody else is terrible he
couldn't possibly have done anything any
sooner any better any more competently
in any way whatsoever anybody who wants
a test can get one everything is free
everything's available wash your hands
and this will be over in about two weeks
maybe somebody can actually clip that
that would be a good maybe thing to post
okay let me say thank you to a whole
bunch of different people big Luna has
grabbed a twitch prime sub at least a
little has subscribed disillusioned has
subscribed Tammy neuen and zombie GX as
well as vol space and R Dodds Hobbes irk
and set t tov designer drugs is a new
subscriber superscope Zam's a BAM all of
these people have just signed
and they are all very very good people
let me say thanks to new members I think
we might be at twenty five new member
number 21 is Thomas Randa at join
pakman.com Chad Johnston is new member
number 22
Sean Brent ling'er is new member number
23
Cory Potter is new member number 24
Yaroslav Lagoon Enco is new member
number 25 today and a Brad Falkner Brad
Faulkner is new member number 26
if you have been enjoying to the extent
that any of us can enjoy coverage of a
tragic pandemic which the government is
woefully Mis handling but if you've
appreciated the coverage I think is
better said do consider grabbing a
subscription at join pakman.com that
also under writes live streams of
debates like we will have on Sunday
evening with Bernard Sanders and Joseph
R Biden Jr it under writes the live
election results which we will have on
Tuesday evening so on and so forth okay
all right let's see here
super chats that have been coming in so
many have come in I'm gonna try to get
to some of them here Casey Bates says I
love listening to this and laughing and
then also looking up and seeing David
chuckling in dismay like and subscribe
viewers thank you phone eek the second
says wrote you an article on Twitter
please look for it alright my Twitter my
Twitter has imploded something insane
has happened on Twitter usually I can't
use my normal mentions feed because it's
too crazy so I go over and look at the
Oh at the verified one the verified one
is too crazy to even know what's going
on also hilariously I tweeted that there
was something weird about so many
companies seemingly underwriting this
coronavirus crisis and some kind of like
retail lobbyists wrote to me about how
great it is it's crazy what's going on
on Twitter okay any ghost says damn this
dude throws foul Chi the only dude
making these idiots look halfway
competent under the bus that quick
who threw him under the bus was it Trump
who threw him under the bus
imagine says ammo is better than money
waffles der awful says us missed the
critical phase
will steamroll everyone just calm down
says sorry I can't take any more thanks
for streaming numb nunya business says
HFS that must have been one hell of a P
tape not Brandon says did in South Korea
take care of their virus problem back in
late December they got on that real fast
bherumal H says now to lead us in prayer
close print personal friend of mine
great guy mr. Ronald McDonald yeah I was
expecting the McDonald's CEO to say they
were gonna have hand sanitizer inside of
happy meals or something
Jeremih complaining about losing brain
cells during the conference
Sam Dean points out the pronunciations
address industry the guy can't combine
any basic level of valid understanding
of pronunciation Australia's still on
board but dude cereal no ym 63 did they
have all those corporations up there to
positively influence the stock market
maybe and the stock market exploding in
the last few minutes as we saw look at
that just incredible and we suspected
this was sort of the goal really really
really stunning stuff c-span also of
course ran the press conference and it
was all all very very crazy joke rockin
Berg asking Universal income until it's
time over a lot of people talking about
that
Laika asking could they manipulate the
dow somehow well not somehow they did it
in exactly the way that you saw squashy
lemur says every one of them is probably
infected now very very probable tam i am
said unbelievable WTF is going on this
is an advertisement joseph van Scoy boy
i guess a pandemic is too big pharma as
war is to military contractors
cockroaches always find a way to profit
in times of crisis Sam Dean says this is
amazing I've never seen anything like
this oh you just said it just as I was
Wow
but seriously what is your greatest fear
throughout this my greatest fear is that
we do not control this that people don't
take it seriously enough that people
keep doing all the things they normally
do we don't get it contained
soon enough and we don't get antivirals
that work in a vaccine and you know 150
million Americans get it that's that's
the concern
thanks to ramekin beast for grabbing at
which Prime subscription as well as
Garnett or gamut 90 and big Luna as well
thank you very much any ghost says it
was very quick but when asked who the
hell fired all those CC people trunk
basically mumbled I didn't do nothing I
don't know what about foul Chee yeah I
guess that is the way I want a carry
pink molinator makes me smile says I'm
in the UK under isolation America is
lagging here thanks David for live yeah
it's bad
cream star has Trump ever taken
responsibility for any failure okay let
me just briefly get to a couple of the
other things I I wanted to point out I
do want to thank Evan Berg Evan Berg is
new member number 27 today at join
pakman.com okay a couple things to go
through very quickly the cumulative
number of cases right now is a hundred
and forty five thousand fifty four
hundred deaths seventy thousand
recovered the number of active cases
which is you know the number of active
vectors is officially fifty-nine
thousand but remember Ohio's public
health officials said we probably have a
hundred and seventeen thousand people
with it if that's the case none of these
numbers are even remotely close in terms
of countries China does continue to keep
clearing roughly 800 to a thousand cases
they have you know around twenty to
forty new cases per day and several you
know a thousand people or so recover
each day so as you can see the number of
new cases in China dropping very very
dramatically because of the very strict
method methods they've put in place
Italy is an absolute mess Italy
continues to climb I mentioned at the
top of the stream a close friend of my
family who I've known since I was a
little kid currently has suspected
coronavirus pneumonia he's in his mid to
late 60s and he is in hospital and new
cases daily in Italy very very bad Iran
is also really in trouble and Iran may
be the only place that had a worse
response than the US or equal
and it's not looking good in Iran
South Korea wisely does have this very
much under control as you can see the
number of new cases diminishing pretty
significantly since March 3rd now what
what it would be what we really need to
know is from the point at which more
drastic measures are put in how long
does it take until you see the decline
so that the decline sort of started on
March 3rd how long before that did the
extraordinary methods go into place you
will also notice and this is merely
observational if you look at the death
rates in Germany 8 over 3600 Switzerland
11 over 1100 that's 1% Norway one out of
a thousand
that's 0.1% Sweden Netherlands Denmark
and UK the death rates are
extraordinarily low we don't yet know
whether it's simply early and there
there are more recent infections and the
death rates are going to go up or if
they are actually handling treatment in
a better way we just don't know okay
moving on
worst case estimate for us coronavirus
deaths the numbers that now are being
suggested by a bunch of different teams
the worst case scenario would be a
hundred and sixty million to two hundred
and fourteen million infections
that's one projection it could be a
period of months or even a year with
infections concentrated in shorter
spirit periods and as many as 200,000 or
1.7 million people could die that's sort
of the the worst case that we've seen so
far for the United States this is
another dashboard that I encourage
people to take a look at it has some
advantages over the world ah meters dot
info and some disadvantages I do like
that you can not only look at confirmed
cases cumulatively but also active cases
and when you look at China for example
you see that the cumulative case bubble
is much larger than the active case this
helps to understand confirmed cumulative
confirm tells us who has had the most
cases active tells us what places are
the biggest vectors for contagion right
now again another estimate of this one a
hundred and fifty million Americans
could get
coronavirus the the top-end estimate
would be 214 million as of right now and
again these are worst-case scenarios
that are meant to shock people they are
meant to get people to say I have to
think about my behavior and I need to
adjust it a lot of problems in a lot of
different places where people are just
mobbing grocery stores Trader Joe's
targets etc the pictures are ugly it's
crazy what is going on and again
stuff like toilet paper there's as far
as I know and correct me if I'm wrong
there is no reason to think that there
will be a shortage of the of the toilet
paper production flow supply chain
unless people go in stockpile toilet
paper which people are doing again so I
don't I don't really understand that you
know empty shelves everywhere we're
seeing this everywhere people buying you
know 50-pound bags of rice look at the
size of this cheerio box this is a
Costco afterall so I am concerned about
this because of the the panic breeds
panic people hear about people buying
stuff so then they go and buy stuff and
you know I what I've done is I've slowly
accumulated some non-perishable so if I
wasn't able to go to the grocery store
for a couple of weeks I'd be able to
make I mean what did I get I basically
got a bunch of different types of pasta
rice and various legumes lentils etc
those last for a while I got a bunch of
broths chicken broth vegetable broth etc
and I got a bunch of frozen vegetables
so if need be and some frozen bread if
need be I make some soups
they've got vegetables in them they've
got protein from the lentils or whatever
else I can make soups and then I got
some pasta sauces as well as a variety
of different types of pasta but I'm not
actually using any of that stuff I'm
trying to sort of do my my normal
grocery shopping and I've got you know a
couple of weeks that seems reasonable to
me at this point in time a lot of
traders Joe at Trader Joe's images
coming in Bill DeBlasio having to fight
you know false rumors about quarantines
okay interesting article in the Atlantic
this is a different this is the
political story I don't want to get into
it now but I would recommend people just
look at this
by frozen bread you know there's freezer
bagels and also I get like Ezekiel bread
and just put it in the freezer and then
you can you know you take two slices out
you put it in the oven or a toaster if
you have one I haven't had a toaster for
ten years I just use the oven it does
take a while but it's okay
you just put two slices in the oven ten
minutes you're good the the presidential
pout the declaring an emergency thing we
shouldn't I don't I'm not being
conspiratorial but we shouldn't ignore
thanks for gifting all those subs by the
way we shouldn't ignore that there is a
wide scope of presidential emergency
powers when a national emergency has
been declared we should just be aware of
it I encourage you to read this article
by the Atlantic we already talked if
you're just joining us there is the idea
that REM des aver is an antiviral which
is being used with some early success in
South Korea it was originally developed
I believe by an Israeli company for
Ebola it didn't work well for Ebola
there's the idea that it or a modified
version of it could be used to make many
more kovat 19 cases more mild
significantly less serious the ethical
questions around animal should we do the
full animal testing on vaccines are we
in a situation where we need to more
quickly move on to human testing it's a
medical ethics debate I'm not weighing
in on it I'm merely telling you that
this is another thing that is now being
discussed period and then lastly Donald
Trump mentioning coronavirus org that is
this website and the website let's even
refresh it it may have been updated
since the since the speech was given the
website actually is barely working now
too many people are accessing it and I
it looks like it is um not not
functioning I'm unable to refresh and it
seems as though the website is
functionally not working at this point
in time due to the number of people
trying to access it but coronavirus org
has been established that is that's
basically everything that we know so far
and all all of the new information that
we have okay a couple of other questions
coming in Chloe Callahan asked did they
mention the cost of the test they did
not bran doe says anyone notice how from
energy picked up after the oann chick
asked questions couldn't blame her gave
her the same look he gives to Ivanka
that's brutal
thanks to Lance Cooper and Braun doe for
grabbing YouTube subscriptions chris
says David there are Bernie people
watching this who still won't vote
provide an elderly or sacrificial lambs
for apathy okay I'm not gonna dig into
that now but we have talked about that
before we do have a hype train happening
on Twitch and that's always very
exciting so consider participating if
you are aware of that and that that's
basically the scope of it my plan for
kit so I don't know if people heard this
at the beginning of the stream YouTube
has been flatly D monetizing all
coronavirus content we've been notified
that we are being added to a list of
authoritative opinion channels on
coronavirus and whitelisted meaning that
going forward we will be able to
monetize our coronavirus content and
this is not like you know as I said
before this isn't about trying to make
money from a tragedy its we want to keep
reporting on it we'd be doing it either
way and it's a good thing that we are
not being wrapped in with conspiracy
websites telling you to go and buy
colloidal silver and start drinking it
as some lunatic Christian channels have
been suggesting so that that is good
news but the schedule as of now is if
there are more announcements like they
said maybe Sunday night there would be
announcements about more protocols we
will cover them we will cover the Sunday
night debate between Bernie Sanders and
Joseph R Biden Jr and then we will cover
results on Tuesday Tuesday of Florida
and a number of other states voting so
that that is our plan at this point in
time oh there were a couple other things
yeah that we were going to look at over
here let's look at case statistics this
is the world ahh meters dot info website
and I wanted to go through this a little
bit okay so when we talk about the death
rate people have already talked about
this you can't just divide deaths by
cumulative cases because that does not
give you an accurate number the right
way to calculate the
death rate is you start with this over
the cases with an outcome if someone is
currently sick
what are we dividing by we don't know if
that's a death or not so you have to
divide deaths by total cases with an
outcome when you do that the numbers are
ugly right because it's 7% what you have
to add to that is the likely sort of off
the record cases cases that have not
been confirmed via testing when you do
that obviously the death rate is a
fraction of this we don't know whether
it's 0.4 0.8 1 2 we just don't know and
when you have incomplete data it's hard
to get an actual death rate that's one
thing number two one of the things
that's important to look at is the rate
of new cases because there will come a
time hopefully where we will see fewer
new cases per day but of course the
cumulative number of cases is going to
go up you're going to look at it and
I'll say 150,000 cases and you look the
next day and it'll say 155 that won't
tell you the daily new cases right now
the numbers are going in a very bad
direction as you can see at some point
we would hope that the number of new
cases will start to decline and
eventually you get to something which is
effectively are less than 1 meaning each
person is infecting on average fewer
than one people and on average you are
clearing cases more quickly than you get
new cases so we are gonna see positive
new case numbers for a very very long
time it could be months but what we are
looking for is an inflection point at
which daily new cases start to decline
and it's actually the the real example
of it let me pull it up is what happened
in China when you look at China if you
sort by total cumulative cases China is
at the top if you sort by total deaths
China is at the top if you sort by
active cases China is no longer at the
top the number of active cases in China
is now smaller than the number of in
Italy because China hit that inflection
point they hit it seemingly
on February 12th there was also a change
in measurement or something that
happened on February 12th that made this
number artifis
really high but that's the inflection
point that we were looking at arguably
the inflection point even happened
earlier on February 4th but as you can
see that was five six weeks ago so this
is going to take take some time the
growth factor is that number that I was
talking about and as you can see when
the growth factor is under one that's
good that is if you have a growth factor
under one eventually you get to zero if
you have a growth factor over one of
course that is an expansion 1.15 would
be or one point five nine would be a
fifty-nine percent increase over the oil
a growth factor of one point five nine
means people are on average infecting
one or two other people weighted towards
two because we're at one point five nine
that's what that means case is excluding
mainland China obviously going up
dramatically
eight thousand new ones yesterday and
seven thousand the day before and five
the day before is you see the numbers
are climbing that's not good oh and here
here's that math I was just doing yeah
eighty three hundred seventy two so this
is that's that that's a very very bad
curve and it could continue that growth
factor outside of mainland China
somewhere recently roughly between one
and one point five so that that's I
think that's mostly everything that that
we were going to be looking at there let
me say thank you to as Barty who is new
member number twenty eight today very
much appreciate that I also want to say
thanks to everybody who has grabbed
youtube subscriptions sent super chats
signed up on twitch etc that's going to
do it for today we will continue
following what's going on with
coronavirus live stream of the
democratic debate on sunday night and
also on tuesday night live election
results assuming none of those get
postponed
starting at 8:00 p.m. Eastern